welcome to my complete beginners course
on user authentication in web apps
in this course we're going to be talking
about how do you actually
write that register form or the login
form for your users
using node.js express and
passport.js and then later in the course
we'll actually go into how do we apply
these strategies to
an angular application and then even
further
how do we write our own custom jwt
authentication option but before we get
into that i want to just
introduce myself i'm zach and i'm a full
stack developer
i've got a smaller youtube channel where
i cover a lot of these topics
and i've been writing code for about
four and a half years pretty much every
day at this point
and i'm super excited to share this
particular series because it was one of
the biggest struggles that i had
when i was first learning to code i
struggled with it for
two main reasons number one i was scared
of it
i was scared to write a user
authentication option because
you know everyone talks about you know
infosec and
trying to secure your web apps as
strongly as possible and how there's
always
you know loopholes and bugs and you know
exploits and stuff like that
and so this whole user authentication
topic
was very intimidating to me the second
reason that it was really tough for me
is because everyone made it look so easy
i would watch tutorials where we'd get
through the user authentication section
in about 10 minutes and i was left
just scratching my head because i had no
idea what had just happened
i had copied the code in the tutorial
but i had no idea what was going on
behind the scenes
in this tutorial i want to solve both of
those problems
so with the security side of things
this all gets easier when you realize
that you know when you're first building
your apps
the the prototype version it's not
important to
you know secure your app on a grand
scale like a corporation would have to
the methods i'm going to teach within
this course are perfect for someone
who's just trying to get a basic
auth strategy implemented and put it
into their you know prototype
app or even a small scale business it's
going to be secure enough
for something like that and on the
second point in terms of
understanding what's going on behind the
scenes i really hope that this tutorial
is the most in-depth user authentication
tutorial that you have ever seen
as you can see by the length of this
video it is very
long and the reason being is not because
it takes us
you know this many hours to implement
authentication
but because it takes us this many hours
to understand all of the different
components
that go into an authentication scheme
for example
if we're using passport js we have to
understand middlewares in express
because passport.js
is a middleware and not only that but
it's actually
a little bit more complex middleware
than you're probably
using on a normal basis on the actual
authentication side of things
there's a ton of topics that we don't
really you know associate with user
authentication when we're just trying to
implement it
for example do we understand cookies in
the browser do we understand
http headers that allow us to set those
cookies
do you understand how a json web token
works
what's in the payload of that json web
token and furthermore in the payload
of that json web token we're using
techniques
like hashing algorithms and cryptography
these are not simple topics
there are universities that have entire
curriculums on just cryptography
and concepts associated with it so as
you can imagine
talking through all of these things is
going to take some time
but i can assure you i'm going to walk
you from point a to point b
and i'm not going to leave you hanging
on any part of this tutorial
i genuinely hope that you enjoy it as
much as i enjoyed making it
and at this point i think we're ready to
jump in today we're going to be talking
about
how you can implement user
authentication
in your web applications using node.js
express.js and passport.js
and we're first going to kind of jump
into
what are your authentication options in
general i know that's
a question that i had for a long time
you know what do we have i hear stuff
about jwt
username and password and then you've
got all this other stuff like
oauth and even some custom
strategies that you can use to
authenticate your users so we'll go
through that
then we'll talk a little bit about the
passport js
framework what it is what kind of
structure
does it use to authenticate users into
the apps
and then what are some of the different
strategies that
you can use within it and then finally
we'll actually go into the
implementation of
the passport local strategy in the
passport jwt strategy
although we'll talk about which
strategies we might use in
different situations both of these
strategies are going to be really good
for
anyone who is just trying to get their
app
off the ground and their primary focus
is not necessarily on authentication but
they actually
need authentication to get it off the
ground so
these are kind of like the the bare
bones um
most basic way to authenticate users
into an application and it's going to be
great for
you know individuals small teams
startups
anyone that is building their
application from scratch
there are a few prerequisites for this
tutorial series
i've pretty much assumed that you
already know the basics of coding
within the node.js ecosystem so
that means you know you have a pretty
good understanding
of node.js modules and
package.jsons all of that kind of stuff
as well as things like the express
framework
also things like asynchronous
programming so promises and callbacks
hopefully you're at least a little bit
familiar with all of the topics here on
the screen
if not you can still get through the
tutorial but i would highly suggest
kind of brushing up on anything that
you're not
you don't have a very basic
understanding of the first thing that i
want to cover
is what are your authentication
options here before we get into any
coding it's pretty
important to take a look at what's
available to us
and deciding what is my use case and
what's going to be best for that use
case
so on the screen i've laid out all of
the
authentication options that you might
find
if you are in the node.js ecosystem
or any other ecosystem for that matter
and they are listed from least complex
to most complex but that does not mean
that the least complex option
is the worst option it just means that
as you kind of move up that chain it's
going to require a little bit
more understanding
more pieces that you have to understand
to implement the strategy itself
in the scope of this tutorial series
we're just going to be sticking with the
left two
so the session based authentication
aka the passport local strategy and
the json web token or jwt
authentication or aka the
passport jwt strategy now you also have
a little bit more complex
authentication that you'll see
especially if you're trying to use
um a large api like maybe the youtube
api
or any google api um even github's api
these big companies rely on oauth
it's just a protocol to give
different access rights to
users trying to access resources within
their api
so you'll kind of get the
gist of what that is as we get into the
jwt authentication but
i'm going to stay away from completely
diving into the oauth
although we're not going to actually get
into the the coding
implementation of solutions like oauth
or even
custom solutions it's definitely
important to at least touch on it
so what oauth is all about it's
it's just a protocol and i know that can
get pretty confusing when you have
um software as a service providers such
as
auth0 and octa among others
that actually provide this oauth
protocol as a service so you
it's really confusing if you look at
those companies
you know namely one that's named off
zero which sounds like a protocol
it gets really jumbled in your head like
what's the protocol what's the company
you know how is all this working so
really what oauth what the oauth
protocol
aims to do is separate out
the two components of
we'll call user authentication i got to
be careful with the terminology here
because
there's a big difference between
authorization
and authentication so on the left with
the jwts
and the local logins the session based
authentication that is all about
knowing who the user is and that is what
we would call
authentication now on the other side of
things
if you have seen things like social
logins
like sign in with google or sign in with
facebook
that's a little bit more about
authorization
so that's kind of it's not as much who
who we're
talking about but instead who has
access to what resources so in other
words you'll get into things like
scopes you know what does this
particular
subject or user have
authorization to access does it have
authorization to make
just get requests against the api or
does it also have
authorization to edit certain resources
within the api so as you might guess
using the oauth protocol and you'll also
hear things like
open id connect is closely related
that is going to be used with these
bigger services
where you know maybe one company such as
google
allows users that have
varying authorizations to access the api
in the same way so if i or you
wanted to access resources from say
google's youtube data api so if we
wanted to get youtube analytics
or something like that we don't have
authorization
to do certain things within that api
and that is defined by the scopes that
we
are basically provided in our access
token
that's related to the oauth protocol now
i know all that sounds
very complex and it's definitely not
something
that you can even begin to understand
completely in just a few minutes but i
did want to talk about that
um and kind of just mention what it is
and why we're not going to
get into all the details of it i think
we have plenty on our plate
with the session based authentication
and the jwt based authentication
to even start talking about that so
those are your options
we're going to stick with the two on the
left the least complex ones
and probably the most common
implementations that you'll see
for startups and people who are just
trying to get their application
off the ground and worry about the
complex authentication of it a little
bit later down the road
when they have either more resources
more money
or both that can actually spend the time
to implement something
a little bit more complex like the oauth
protocol
to wrap up this introductory video i
wanted to
give a brief overview of what the
passport.js
framework is and the reason being
is we're actually going to be
implementing
two different strategies within the
passport framework
but that just basically means that we
have
two different middlewares that are
connecting into the bigger
passport js middleware so you might ask
what is a middleware
for those that are not familiar what
middlewares are in express
or are just a little bit fuzzy on how
they work
i have created a video that will be
included in this playlist so that you
can brush up on that
and get yourself up to speed but
basically
all that passport js is is a middleware
that integrates within your express.js
application and handles all of the
authentication logic
using the specific strategy that you
choose
to plug into the passport.js framework
now the strategies that are included if
we go to
passport js
we can go to the home page and see that
there are plenty of different strategies
here
so we can do anything from the passport
local
and passport jwt like we're doing and we
can also do something a lot more
complex you can see that we have stuff
like the passport oauth 2 which is what
we just talked about
or even you know something more specific
passport instagram we can use the
instagram login to authenticate our
and delegate access to our users
so there's a lot of different strategies
and all of these strategies have been
created by
independent developers that basically
say okay
here's the passport.js framework it's
just a middleware
and it allows me to kind of use
that framework as a starting point and
then we can just build in the
the specific pieces of authentication
in our own middleware which we call a
strategy
so in summary passport js is just
a framework that is a middleware that
also
allows individual developers to develop
other middlewares called strategies that
connect in with this bigger
middleware that we call the passport.js
framework
and then all of that gets wrapped up
into a bundle
and put into your express app and it
works seamlessly
with your express routes we'll see
in a lot more detail how each of these
strategies the local
and jwt strategy work as we go through
the series but it is important to just
understand the basics
of what this is if i had to sum up the
code logic of passport.js in a few
sentences
it would basically be this so
passport.js
is a middleware as we just talked about
and on every http request
that a user calls to our express
server the passport framework is going
to
first pick up okay what strategy are we
using here
and then it will use that strategy to
say
hey is that user that just requested
that resource
authenticated if that user is
authenticated
then passport is going to let that user
access the resource it's going to you
know go into the express route
if that user is not authenticated based
on the strategy we're using
then passport is going to return a 401
http status which is basically the
unauthorized status
so that's kind of passport.js in a
nutshell again
it's going to get a lot easier as we see
the actual code flow
of what's going on with this middleware
congratulations you made it through the
first part
of this super long tutorial on user
authentication
now we talked about all the different
options here and we're not going to be
covering some of those delegated
authentication options but there's
plenty to cover with the other ones
and particularly with the passport local
authentication strategy where we're
going to be using the express session
middleware
having a solid understanding of http
headers and http cookies is going to be
absolutely essential as a web developer
you go on a bunch of different sites and
you click that accept button when they
say
you know we use cookies on this website
but you actually
know what that means i think you're
going to find this section
interesting but let's go ahead and dive
in what
is an http header i think it's something
that we
know in the back of our heads kind of
what it is
especially if we program a lot of web
apps but
it's also something that we don't spend
a lot of time
trying to learn and we frankly don't
need to learn
a whole lot about them that said we do
need to specifically learn
about an http header called the set
cookie
and the cookie header in order to
understand how
server-side sessions work and kind of
interact with the browser
so if we come to google.com right here
i always use this as an example just
because it's pretty arbitrary spot
if you open up your developer
console here in google chrome and go to
the network tab
you'll see that it is pretty much empty
right now but if we click refresh
on the google search and we're basically
doing a get request
to google.com and you'll see a bunch of
stuff loading a lot of these are the
resources that run the page
or scripts but at the top you see this
www.google.com if we click on this
you'll see that there are some headers
here
and you'll see that the headers come in
three basic categories
first you have the general headers then
you have the response headers
and finally the request headers
what we're specifically interested in
in this case to understand what a cookie
is and how it works
is the request and the response headers
but we can also kind of explore the rest
you can go on to mdn is a great place to
look and you can see there's
you know a link to all sorts of
different headers
so we can go down here into security
and these are all the different security
headers that you could set
in either the general response or
request
headers now let's take a step back and
really think about what just happened
when we pressed the refresh button
in our browser to load google.com
if you think about it a http client
could be
anything from an iot device
someone like me sitting at my desk or at
a coffee shop
you could think of it as just a laptop
or a phone
pretty much anything that connects to
the internet is considered
an http client now on the other side of
things
is all of the http servers and those
servers
google in this case is going to house
the information
that the clients want to access or
update or do other operations on
so in our case what we did was do
a get request to google.com in other
words we want the resources
at that web page so if you look at the
headers here
in the chrome tools you'll see
as we talked about we have these three
categories so let's just go ahead and
walk through each of them
and see what was relevant to our request
so in the the first one the general
headers
these can be either request or response
related
they're just kind of general metadata
about the request
such as what is the url that we're
requesting
what type of method are we using so this
is a get request
those were both probably those are in
the request
side of things now if we go to the
response side of things
you'll see that we got a status code of
200
which means that we requested data from
google
and it sent back the data successfully
so you can see that we have several you
know
things that kind of mix between the
request and response
now in our particular situation when we
searched google
we formed or we didn't form but the
browser that we were using
created a request header which is
basically
instructions for the server in
what data you know the request wants so
i'm the client here sitting at my
computer so the the browser on my behalf
is going to say
hey whoever i'm trying to get these
resources from
i'm going to put in the request headers
what kind of data i
accept so you can see that we have
things like the accept
encoding except language and then just
the accept
http header and we're basically saying
that we
accept html we
accept xml and a couple other different
options
but you can just think of this request
header as the instructions for
the server that you're requesting
resources from or
trying to modify what type of data that
the client
myself will accept in the browser is not
the only thing that you can put in this
request header
you can put all sorts of other things
you see there's a cookie in here we'll
talk about that in a few minutes
but you also have things like the user
agent tells us what browser is
requesting this data
and then if again you can go to the mdn
site
and look at a broad variety of different
things that you could put
in the request header so you can click
on the request
context and you can kind of see some of
the things that you can put in that
so we know that http headers are
basically
metadata about our our http
request so we can also do that
on the response which would be set by
the server
which in this case is google so one of
google's servers whichever
gave us the content that we're viewing
on the web right now
is going to set these response headers
and these response headers are going to
give
additional instructions to the client
that requested the data in the first
place
so you can go through a couple of these
and see
you can see the content type so if you
remember in the request header
our you know the client which is the
browser i'm sitting in
and using right now said i only accept a
certain type of data
and then the response is going to say
okay you only accept that type of data
here's the data and here is what type it
is
so this is useful if you know we're
trying to figure out how to display that
data in the browser
of course there are other things that
that you'll see here but
i want to direct your attention to
something very relevant to what we're
talking about right now
which is the set cookie header
now you can see that the set cookie
header is basically giving
key value pairs and you can see
you know right here it says expires
equals friday the 31st of january 2020
at this specific time so you might be
asking
well there's a cookie header in the
request
object and there was a cookie header in
the response
object how can that be what is the
difference between the two and how do
they work
over the next few minutes i'm going to
walk you through exactly how
the set cookie and the cookie headers
kind of work together
and then in another video we'll actually
talk about how this all plays
into what we call a server-side session
the easiest way to understand what a
cookie is and how it works
is to remember that http protocol
is a stateless protocol in other words
it's going to constantly forget what the
user has done
on the site unless we have a way to
remember that
so in other words if we go to google
let's just imagine the scenario
we go to google and we sign in to google
and we'll just assume they actually
probably don't use this method but
we'll just assume that they're using
cookies and server side sessions to
authenticate us
so what happens is google the server
is going to say okay the client that
just
you know signed in gave us valid
credentials
and so what we want to do is you know
send
something back that allows the browser
to remember that this user has logged in
if we don't have anything like cookies
or
local storage probably more modern way
to do it
if we don't have these types of
persistent storage
then every time we refresh the page
our the state that we had previously
where google said okay
we logged you in is going to have to be
redone
so every time you refresh the page
you're going to have to enter your login
credentials which of course is a
terrible user experience
and any site that does that is going to
lose their users immediately because
they're going to get
completely tired of typing in their
login credentials so this is where the
set cookie and cookie headers come in
so let's do a little experiment here and
i know this is not a perfect example but
i think
it will do for what we're trying to
accomplish here so let's click on the
application
and open up cookies for google you'll
see that there's all sorts of cookies
you know google knows everything about
everyone so
we can just go ahead and delete these it
doesn't hurt anything to delete all
these cookies
so at the moment our browser has no
cookie set
whatsoever so we can come back to the
network tab
and let's go ahead and refresh the page
once more
you'll see that we had this google.com
here and we can open up the response
and request headers and you'll see that
the request headers it's pretty much
the same as what we had looked at before
and then in the response headers
we once again have these set cookie
headers
and what these are doing is basically
saying
okay or the the google server is saying
okay client i want to set this
information
about you so we'll just assume maybe we
just logged in
and google wants to tell the browser
that
i the client is logged in and we don't
need to
re-authenticate every single time that
we've refreshed the page
so what happens here is we have these
set cookie
headers and let's just pick a very
specific
key value pair here just to see what's
actually happening
so let's get a pretty easy one
we'll just say the 1p jar
it gives us a date of 2020 1-21
i'm not exactly sure what that means but
keep this in mind this is what we're
going to be looking for
so if you go to the application
you'll see that now these are set
in the cookies field so we have the 1p
jar and then the value that was set
in this response header
so now what our browser will do
is it says okay now we have a cookie set
so
every request that we make within this
domain
so google.com i want to attach
those cookies that were set based on
this set
cookie http header in the response
header
so what's going to happen is when we
press
refresh again it's going to actually put
these cookies in the request headers
so right here in this cookie request
header we should see
something like these set cookies that
google
the server had put into our browser so
let's click refresh
once more go to thegoogle.com
and look at the request headers and you
can see that now this
cookie header right here has that 1p
underscore jar cookie key
value pair so just to recap what just
happened
we had a client me refreshing or
doing a get request against google.com
and whatever google server that gave me
that data
said i want to set a cookie
in this client's browser so it uses the
response header to do that
it assigns these values in the set
cookie
header and then when we reload the page
our google chrome browser or any browser
for that matter
is going to say okay my default behavior
is this
is to look up what cookies are currently
set in my browser
and i'm going to attach those cookies to
every single request
for the domain context that it is
applicable to which is google.com in
this matter
if you really think about it this method
of setting
and then the browser just attaching the
cookie to each request
is a really powerful thing when it comes
to user authentication
you could say hey maybe my server can do
some sort of logic
and say okay is that user valid
invalid did they give me the right
password if they authenticated correctly
then i do the set cookie header
in the response object and then now the
user or the client
that is using my web application
now has that cookie that says yes this
user has already been authenticated and
then the browser every time it reloads
will
attach that cookie and you don't have to
re-log in that user
now the real question is how long do we
keep that user logged in
and that's a totally arbitrary question
but we can do that with the expires
piece
of this set cookie http header
if we come over to the network tab
and look at the response headers from
google
you'll see that there's the cookie
that's being set
so 1p jar it looks like this is actually
set on every
get request to google but you'll notice
that it has an expires piece to it
so this is what tells the browser how
long to store that cookie key value pair
within the the client so we can actually
go through this
exercise on our own using some simple
javascript
to see exactly how it's working so let's
go to the console
and type in a few quick commands so
first we're going to create a new date
which is going to represent the date and
time
right when i click enter so we'll say
enter and then we're going to say
we want to set the time 20 seconds later
so let's do that and then finally let's
set
a cookie to the browser with the an
expires header
at that time so we really only have a
few seconds
but you can see that we have a custom
cookie
that's going to be there for about 20
seconds so if we reload right now
it shows that it's gone so let's go
ahead and do that one more time
a little bit quicker this time so here's
our cookie
go over to application you'll see that
we have the custom cookie
and every time we refresh the browser
you're going to see that cookie is going
to stay there
but then in about 20 seconds which is
coming up here in a few seconds i think
you'll see that that cookie actually
will drop off
and it will no longer be attached to the
http request
so if we refresh you'll see it's gone
and
that user will say that that was a
cookie that
gave a user or the client's
authentication status
that's gone the user has to re-login now
obviously you're not going to set
a cookie to last for 20 seconds you
might more realistically say
that you want the cookie to last for two
weeks
and that is a really powerful way to
keep some sort of persistent state
within the browser
and not require users to log in
every time they refresh the page the
next part
of this tutorial is all about express
middleware
in order for us to implement the
passport local strategy which
utilizes express session we're going to
have to understand middleware and that's
because both passport.js
and express session are both middlewares
if you don't understand this concept
really well
then both of those libraries are going
to be confusing to you
furthermore i'd consider this one of the
most essential topics of programming in
the express framework while the official
express documentation
does cover express middlewares in some
capacity and it's relatively clear
when i was a beginner i'd never
understood it fully
and even to the point you know two years
into my programming journey
i still did not have a solid grasp on
this express middleware
after learning it in depth for the first
time i can really
confidently say that this is going to be
one of the most important lessons that
you learn
you know as a node.js developer using
that express framework
so without further ado let's dive into
this express middleware
overview when you start out using
express.js as a framework
it's an entirely middleware based
framework but
generally when you first learn it you're
just copying
in you know the different pieces and you
know that there's
kind of something working behind the
scenes but you don't know exactly how
it's working
so in this video we're going to talk
about how exactly does this middleware
work
and how does the request response and
next or callback object as well as even
the air object work in express
application in order to do this we need
to
spin up a really quick basic application
um what i'm working in here again this
is part of the passport.js series so i'm
in the repository that we're using for
that
but don't worry this is just a basic
express app
so we first need to require in
express i've already installed this with
npm
so i don't need to do that and then we
say
app equals express and then we just say
app.listen on port 3000
so right there is the most basic form
of an express server that you can spin
up
and if we were to visit localhost 3000
we're not going to get anything
but if we just throw in one simple route
app.get
and then we pass in the request
response and next objects
and then we send some sort of data
we can now run this in the browser so
let's
use nodemon which is going to
automatically update
on every time i save and we'll run
app.js
so we're running app.js it's listening
on
port 3000 and it'll be listening on
localhost
so if we go to the browser and visit
localhost 3000
port 3000 you should see the hello world
so we have a basic server running and
that's all we need to do to start
understanding how middleware works
in express so we come back to the code
here
and the first thing that you need to
understand is
this right here so with our app.get
this is just a route that we've
established in our express
application we are passing in
a route string and a callback function
usually you'll see it in this syntax but
to better understand it we can just
basically write
a function where we say request
response and next now to make this even
more
transparent what i'm going to do is name
these
custom properties so
normally you're going to just see it r r
e q
r e s for request and response and then
next
but you don't need to call them that
it's just always going to be passed in
you can call them whatever you want so
we can say request
object response
object and callback function
so well actually we probably shouldn't
call it the callback function
we should say maybe next
middleware or something like that
because the purpose of
this last parameter is if we call it as
a function it will pass it to the next
middleware in the chain
so we'll understand that a little bit
better in a second
but first let's go ahead and write our
function so we need to give it a
function name so we'll just say
standard express callback
and we pass in these three parameters
and then we can say res.send
and hello world
so basically we've got the same exact
thing that we had below
in the app.git route to implement this
let's just delete what we
wrote here and let's just pass in
our standard express callback so we've
defined it up here
we know that express as a framework is
going to pass
in these three parameters
and so there we can just throw it into
our route
and click save and then if we come to
the browser again
if we refresh the page it's going to say
res is not defined and the reason being
is because i
was dumb and forgot to update that so
now that we're passing in request and
response object we obviously need to
also use that in the body of the
function
so that was just a silly mistake but now
if we come to the browser and do it
again
we should get hello world as we expected
so that's the most basic way that an
express route works
and we're using this function that we
had defined
so just like we could define this
function
we can also define other functions which
we call
middleware so the way that we do that
is pretty simple we'll just say
middleware one and
what we need to do is pass in those same
three objects
that we were using before so the request
object response object
in next middleware or whatever you want
to call them
in this case i'll just say record req
res and next like you would normally see
it
and then we can do whatever we want in
this middleware
so maybe we'll just say console.log
i am a middleware
and then in this one this is the
standard express callback
this is where we return some data we can
say console.log
i am the standard express
function so
if we just define that function up here
and we don't do anything with it
it's not going to do anything obviously
but we can pass that
into our route to make it work
for us so let's pass in the middleware
one
and a comma so you can see that
express as a framework allows you to
pass in pretty much as many parameters
to the different route functions as you
want
let's go ahead and save this real quick
um let me open up the terminal a little
bit more so that we can
see what's going on and let's go to the
browser
and visit that same route we'll go ahead
and click refresh here
and you're gonna see that this is gonna
just keep loading
it's not gonna ever return us data and
if we were to
you know copy this into a new tab and
click enter
it's not gonna actually return us
anything and that
brings up a very good point with express
middleware
if we come back to our code that we
wrote
you'll notice that in this middleware
that we passed into
our route that we were visiting
we haven't actually called this next
parameter
so in the express framework the next
parameter is going to be
actually a function and all we have
to do is call it at the bottom
of our middleware and what that's going
to do is it's going to say
for this route right here we first run
middleware middleware number one or
middleware one and in middleware one
we call the next function that was
passed in as a parameter by default by
express and when we call that it's going
to basically say
okay now we get to go to the next
middleware or
in this case it's the last one it's the
standard express
callback so if we don't put that
next function and call it it's never
going to get to this
last function and we're not going to
ever return
any data so now that we've called this
next function
we should be able to go back to the
browser
and see a response so if we refresh
we'll see that it should return hello
world
and you see that it did return it and if
we come back to
our code again you'll see in the console
that we printed i actually ran this
route twice so we printed i am a
middleware and then i am the standard
express function
and the order of this is very important
because
first in the route we run this
middleware
and then we run the standard express
callback
so first we're going to console.log i am
a middleware
second we're going to console.log i am
an express function
so that is the basics of how this
middleware works
but we also have a few other things to
understand
so what we've been using so far by
passing the middleware
into the route itself is a route
specific middleware
now this is kind of i just think of it
this way i don't know if it's the exact
term that you would use
but i call this a route specific
middleware but you also can have
global middleware so if i took this out
of the route
and i came up to the top right under the
definition for the app
and i say app.use
what this function built into express
expects
is a function or a middleware that it
can execute
so in this case i'm going to just take
middleware number one or middleware one
and say app.use middleware1
so what's going to happen is the express
app
is going to initialize and then
it's going to initialize the middleware
one
so let's go ahead and see what happens
in the console
when we do this so i'll let me make sure
i got this right so we've got
our middleware defined here we call next
and we're
initializing it with the app.use up here
so let's save that
and you'll see that nothing has happened
in the console yet
you might expect since we did this
outside of a route
that it would just automatically print i
am a middleware
and go to the next something but that's
not the case when we
say app.use it's basically just
adding a piece to that chain of
functions or middlewares that we're
going to be calling
so once again we have to come back to
google chrome
and execute this git route so let's
enter and so it loads correctly and then
if we come back to the code again
now you're going to see i am a
middleware and i am the standard express
function
so what just happened here well first
off
we defined that this is the first
middleware that we want to use
in all of our routes it's not just
specific to
this particular route it's going to
happen in any route that we define
within our application
next we have the standard express
callback
which is in this specific route so first
the route's going to call middleware 1
then it's going to com
call whatever we had defined as the
callback to that route
so the order of the middleware that we
define
in the scope whether it's a global or a
route specific middleware
really matters so let's go ahead and see
what happens if we switch up the order
of the middleware and maybe even add
another middleware into
this equation so let's say we have
another middleware called middleware
2 and again we pass in the default
objects that we are provided by
or provided with by the express
framework
and we'll say console.log
i am middleware number two
and maybe we should just update this one
up here
to number one so we've got middleware
number one and middleware number two
and what i'm going to do is say app.use
middleware to okay
so we are using two middlewares and then
we have the standard express callback
which at this point i'm just going to go
ahead and put it
in a form that we're used to seeing
so we'll just use request res and next
this is what you'll see in most
tutorials so i want to keep it
consistent
so let's copy that in there delete the
function declaration
and then of course since we changed the
name of the parameter we need to also
change the name of the object that we're
using to send the data
all right so let's just quickly recap
what we got
we have one route in our application
which has a very standard syntax
all we're doing is we're sending back an
h1 tag with hello world in it
so far in this route we haven't defined
any route specific middleware
but we have defined global middleware
so let's see what happens go ahead and
kind of make your guess as to what's
going to happen here
but if i had to guess we're probably
going to print
i middleware number one and then i am
middleware number two
when we call that route and then finally
we'll
you know console.log i am the standard
express function
all right so we've saved it let's go
back to the browser
click refresh
and i don't know why it hangs sometimes
here
try it again maybe we have some sort of
air did a little bit of refactoring
nope it was doing just fine we've got
all the things that we expected so if
you could guess what's actually
happening here
is again we forgot to call the next
function
in the middleware 2 so it never reached
this final function
save it once more come to the browser
once more and refresh we should get a
good response
come back to the code and you'll see i
am middleware number one
i am middleware number two and i am the
standard express function
all right so everything is as expected
and now
is where the real you know understanding
comes into play
because oftentimes when we're using an
express application
we've got all sorts of middleware
working together in most
express applications you're going to
have several
app.use statements so you might say
app.use course cross-origin resource
sharing
that's a pretty common one or app.use
body parser and then whatever the
configuration for that was
so you might have up to like 10 15 even
20 different
middlewares that you are adding to your
express application
and so it's really important to
understand that the order
that we put these in matters so if we
were to put middleware 1 after
middleware 2 all we did was change the
order of those statements
if we save and then go to the browser
and
call that route you're going to notice
that when we come back to the code
we now have things out of order so we
have i am middleware number two coming
before
number one so that's really important to
understand
and then of course if you put one of
these within the route itself
it affects the order as well so let's
add one more middleware to this equation
and it's just let's just copy this do
the same thing
so we'll call this one number three
number three right there and then we're
gonna take middleware number three
and put it in the route itself so let's
copy it right there
give it a comma and now what's going to
happen
is we should have middleware 2 called
first
then middleware 1 then it goes into the
route specific middleware
so then we have middleware three and
then finally this last function which
we technically could call middleware as
well
so let's see if that worked we should
have
middleware two one then three
so let's go to the browser
run the route come back to our code
and you see that we have two one and
three exactly how we defined it two
1 and then the route specific middleware
there are two more things that i want to
talk about when
covering the topic of express middleware
and one of those is air handling because
an air handler in express is also just
another middleware
but it's actually a special type of
middleware
so in order to define an air handling
middleware what we have to do is define
a function with a fourth
parameter so let's go ahead and define a
function
called air handler
and you'll see that in this app i've
kind of simplified it a little bit so we
only have one middleware we got rid of
all the rest of the stuff
but this time we're going to pass in an
error
parameter then the request res and next
parameters so this is how we define
an error handling function and we can
you know this is basically a middleware
so we can do as many error handlers as
we want
so if we wanted to catch specific types
of errors
so we say if air dot
status equals something then
we want to you know handle it in this
one and then we could come down and
do another error handler and say this is
error handler number two and if error
air dot status is number two number one
you kind of get the point we can define
as many of these as we want
and handle different types of errors
depending on the application that we're
doing
but what is going to happen here is
this error parameter will be populated
with an error if it exists
so what we can do is we can say
something like
[Music]
maybe instead of throwing the air
explicitly we'll say
if there's an error what we can do is
res.send
and we can say there was
an error please try again
so something more friendly than a
default error that you would
you might get in the browser that would
crash the entire application
so let's go ahead and comment this out
for one second and see what happens
if we don't have an air handler so right
now we don't have an air handler
and maybe in this middleware up here
instead of console logging i'm a
middleware and continuing to the next
we can say that we have an air object
which is a new node.js air so
i am an air and what we can do with this
is we can pass it
in the next function
so normally we just call next and it
goes to the next middleware
this case we're going to actually pass
the air object so this would be
common you know this would be more
common in a scenario where maybe our
middleware was doing something complex
we were making a database call and we
were just
catching any errors that happened with
the database
something that we cannot control so we
always want to catch these
errors and if we do catch them we want
to pass them in the next
function so when we do that
we're going to go back to the browser
real quick
and if we refresh this it's going to say
i am an heir
and you're going to get the entire stack
trace which
you don't want because this is where the
users will see
what's going on and you obviously don't
want to send
this type of error to a user you want to
handle it in a more graceful way
and not to mention if we do it like this
you can see down in the console or in
the terminal
that we've crashed our application so if
this is running
out on a server somewhere and we don't
know that this has happened
our application could be down for hours
without us even knowing
so it's really really important that we
use an error handler in our express
application
to catch these errors and handle them
gracefully without crashing
the express application so again
air handler just another middleware with
one extra parameter
so let's uncomment this air handler
function
and normally you'd set this up a little
bit
more complex than what i've done but
we'll just go with this for now just to
demonstrate the point
so we've got the error handler and so
now we're going to say
app.use air handler
now we'll go to the browser again we'll
refresh
and now we're getting a more friendly
error message
now that we've defined this error
handler let's go ahead
and put it in as a middleware so let's
just say
app.use air handler
and click save now let's come back to
the browser
real quick and refresh
you're going to see this dreaded error
message in the browser
you're going to ask yourself why we
defined our
air handling middleware so we should
have a friendly message here
well what's happening is we have done
this out of order
and like i said earlier in this video
the order that you put
express middleware in matters and in
this case
we need to throw our air handler at the
very
end of our app so after all of our
routes and all of our middleware
we need to put our air handler and the
reason being
is because if there is an air in any of
our middlewares
or our routes which are basically just
middlewares
then the air is going to be passed
directly to
the final air handler so
in this case we have the air happening
up in our first
middleware so what's going to happen
when we say
next and then air express is going to
pick up on this and say
oh there's an error let's send it past
you know let's skip the route here
we don't need to go into this we need to
just go straight to the air handler
and handle it appropriately so this is
kind of how
express middleware works and
you can see that this will more
gracefully
handle the air if we come back to the
browser and refresh
now we're getting a much used more
user-friendly message
in many cases you might do something
instead of
actually sending data like this we could
just say
res.json and then we could say
air and then our front end
application could handle this error on
the front end rather than
you know the server handling it alright
so we have covered how to handle
errors using air handling middleware and
finally the last thing that i think is
important to cover when it comes to
express middleware
is the fact that we can actually mutate
or kind of append different
properties and objects and functions
to these parameters that we're passing
through each of the middlewares
so what we could do here is let's
once again let's get rid of the error in
this middleware
let's also get rid of the console.log we
just want to
have a basic middleware let's call this
number one again
then let's say number two
and let's put these in as global
middlewares
so here's middleware one and two so
first our route's going to call
middleware one
then two and then the actual callback
for the route
so to demonstrate this let's go ahead
come up to middleware one
and say something like request
dot custom property equals
100. all right so we just created a
variable that is attached to the request
object now since we're passing since
express
as a framework passes this request and
response
object through each of the middlewares
it will actually
be available to us in later middlewares
so what we can do is we can say we
define it up in middleware 1
then in middleware 2 we say console.log
the custom property value is
and then let's put in that custom
property
so in middleware number two we should
print
the custom property value is 100
but then we want to reassign it
so let's say custom property equals
600 just a random number
and then finally down in our routes
we'll say
the value is
and then we'll put in request dot custom
property
and in this case it's probably going to
print or not probably
it will print 600 because we have
modified the property in middleware
number two
so let's save that go to the browser and
see what we get
so we see we see that the value is 600
and that is because we set it in our
second middleware which was the last
middleware that modified that property
now you might be asking what is the
point of this
why did you show me that well the reason
being is because it
helps you to understand how a lot of the
middlewares that we use on a daily basis
in express are actually working so if
you're following along this series
the passport.js series for user
authentication
this is exactly how passport js
which is in express middleware is going
to keep track
of users whether they're authenticated
or not
they the passport middleware is going to
take that request
object and it's going to actually append
different properties to it
and also if you watched the previous
video
in this series on the express sessions
middleware
you also know that the request.session
object
is where the session is stored so you
can see how
powerful this is and how we can actually
store
data within the request object and
you know each of our middlewares can
have access to that data
even if they come way after the
middleware that
first modified the data so that's just
kind of a brief explainer
of how middleware works in express
and how air handling middleware works in
express
hopefully it kind of um broadens your
express horizons a little bit i know
when i first learned it it did
um and it made me a lot better express
developer
i now write middleware for all of my
applications to do just
ad hoc things anywhere from
you know authentication guards so maybe
we're checking
a value of a user that we've received
maybe we're checking if they have
administrative rights
and we use a middleware to do that so
the middleware would basically
look up the user in the database check
the admin property
if the admin property is true then we
pass it to the next middleware
if it's false then we might return
something like
401 or 403 unauthorized
http statuses all right after this last
section on express middleware we are now
set up to really understand the express
session library
when you're implementing the passport
local strategy
it uses express session under the hood
which can be
extremely confusing and when you read
through the passport documentation
it doesn't make it abundantly clear that
this is happening
in this section i'm going to teach you
exactly how this express session
middleware is working behind the scenes
kind of independent of the passport js
middleware itself and then we're going
to talk a little bit more about how that
express session
is being looped in to our passport
authentication middleware
now the really cool thing about this
section is that learning the express
session
middleware is not only going to help you
implement a passport local strategy
but it can also be really useful for
other purposes within your web app
well state management is often handled
on the front end
with frameworks like angular vue.js or
react
there is the possibility of handling
some sort of
state or application state on the back
end in the form of a session that is
what the express session library aims to
do
but enough talk let's dive in and
understand all about this library
so in this case we're going to be
looking at a very simple express app
and i'm going to take you through how
the session
is working how the cookies kind of work
with the session
and some of the configuration that you
have to do to set up
the express session middleware what i've
got open right now
is the repository that goes along with
this passport.js
tutorial series and we just have a
folder
for little one-off tutorials like this
one
i've already created an application
which is an express
application and i'm just going to
quickly walk you through what i've done
and then we'll go through what's
actually happening what are some of
these configuration options
so the first thing that i've done i've
already installed my dependencies
we've got express mongoose for the
database and then
express session which is an npm module
we then have something called connect
[ __ ]
which we'll get to in a few minutes it's
what we're going to actually use
for the session store then
of course we set up our express app
pretty familiar to most people
we connect to our database right here so
i'm just using a completely
unauthenticated
localhost database i've got that running
in the background already
so if you're trying to follow along be
sure that you
get the mongodb server or that process
running before you try to run this app
so we're just going to use the tutorial
database
and then these options here are just set
because when you run
the application [ __ ] is going to
complain about it if you don't put these
so that is all we've got and we create
the connection
right here so the connection represents
um our database connection and then down
here we
have some pretty familiar json and url
encoded middleware which is going to
allow the
express server to parse the different
request
types so that just pertains to the type
of
responses that we're getting in on the
server
and then finally we have things related
to
the session itself which we're going to
dive in a little bit deeper
and at the bottom we've just got we're
listening on localhost 3000
and we have one simple route for the
home page
just says hello world sessions so that
is our app
this is the only file we're working with
and so it should be pretty
straightforward
like i said this tutorial is not an
express tutorial
and i assume that you already have a
decent understanding of how the express
framework works i'm trying to stick
primarily to
how the express session middleware works
so if you don't understand how
express works or how middleware works be
sure to check out some
of my other videos or just read some of
the documentation online
before we get into any of the
configuration
and understanding how the express
session works
we need to answer the question what is
the difference between
a session and a cookie you'll see that
in the configuration
i've got a cookie set and in a previous
video that i did
again link is in the description um
we talked about what a cookie was so
basically a session in a cookie are
different
in the places that their data is stored
so a cookie has its data stored in the
browser
and that browser is going to attach that
cookie key value pair
to every http request that it does
a session on the other hand is going to
be stored
on the server side so when i say server
side just the express js
application and so this
express session is going to store a
little bit
bigger types of data so in a cookie you
can't put a whole lot of data
and it gets very tedious if we're
constantly adding more and more data to
the cookie that we're attaching to each
request so
it would make sense to put that in a
server-side session
where we can store much larger amounts
of data
in addition a server-side session is
advantageous because with a cookie we
cannot store
any sort of user credentials
or secret information if we did that
then
a hacker could easily get a hold of that
information
and steal personal data so the benefit
of a session
is basically the fact that we have it on
our server side
and we're actually authenticating into
the session
with a secret key so with that said
that is the main difference between a
cookie and a session
i want you to keep that in mind as we're
talking about the two
in this video now that that's covered
we have some time to get into the actual
code
and configuration of an express session
and then i'm going to show you kind of
how it works in real time
so what we've got on the screen right
now is the express session documentation
it's just an npm module a pretty popular
one at that
and you can see on npmjs.com
there's all the documentation that you
would need to learn how to use this
but i'll just point you towards a few of
the common things that you'll see
first off of course we require in the
express session
and then these options right here
are what are going to be included in
that options object so if you look at
the
code here you'll see that for our
session
we're saying app.use so that's just we
want to use the session
middleware and then we've passed into
the session
middleware an object right here which
represents
our options so if we go back to the
documentation
really quickly you'll see that all of
these options are documented
right here under the options section
now the one thing that i wanted to point
out you get through the options that's
great fine
but then you get to the bottom somewhere
down here
and it talks about a session store
implementation
so if you're unfamiliar with what that
is it's basically
deciding what um persistent memory are
we going to
store our sessions in if you remember
from a few minutes ago i said that a
session
is used to store information about a
particular user moving throughout the
browser or a client
and so we can potentially get up to a
decent amount of information
and therefore in a production
environment it would be
useful to have an actual database
storing that information
now by default the express session
middleware just comes with
its own implementation of a session
store but it's not using a database it's
just using
in memory or memory that's local to your
application
and it's not going to be a scalable
solution
so what we need to do is set up an
actual session store
which is a fancy way of saying we need
to connect
our database to the express session
middleware
so there's going to be a lot of options
for what session stores we can use and
they're documented here at the bottom
the one that we're using particularly is
the connect
[ __ ] session store which is probably
one of the most popular ones
and it allows us right here to connect
to
the mongodb database that we have
running
in our express app so let's go back to
our app real quick and see
what i mean so to do this session store
to connect it up
we first have to have our database
connection
so we talked about this a few minutes
ago here's our connection we're just
using
a tutorial database on localhost
nothing you know you'd obviously want to
change this if you're in production
but we've got this running on my
computer and i can actually come down to
the terminal here
and run the [ __ ] shell and you'll see
that we can
show dbs and you'll see that we have
a tutorial db set up when we connected
to this database
now what we want to do is we want to
tell
the express session middleware that we
want to use that mongodb database
for its session store so you'll see that
that happens
right here in the store option of the
session middleware
and so what we've done is we've passed
in the session store object
into this store option and the session
store object
is set up right here and it is basically
just using that connect
[ __ ] right here the connect [ __ ]
package
and we're configuring a few options
we're saying that the connection
equals the connection that we just set
up and
the collection that we'll be putting our
sessions in
is going to be called sessions pretty
standard
pretty standard option that we have here
you can obviously customize it a little
bit
and if you went to the documentation of
connect [ __ ] there's a few other
options that you can set
but what i want to show you is what is
happening
when we connect everything up so in my
first terminal
i will run this application so let me go
to
the path here and we're going to run the
application
so we are listening on localhost 3000
and if we come into the browser here
i've got this queued up so that we
currently have localhost 3000
ready to go but i have not clicked
refresh yet
the reason being is because i want to
show you exactly what this
middleware the session middleware is
doing
so let's first come back to our
code and what we want to do
is go to the [ __ ] shell and
we want to use the tutorial database
so now we've switched to the tutorial
database let me clear the screen
and we're going to show the collections
that exist
in that database when i ran the app
it initialized this sessions collection
in my database but if i say
db.sessions.find
there's going to only be a couple
objects in here
let me just go ahead and drop this
really quick because i think i had some
stuff from previously
so let's just say db.sessions.drop
so we dropped the database if we show
the collections now
there's nothing but if we were to come
here
and refresh the app so we're using
nodemon so if we click save
it's going to refresh the app we're
going to go into [ __ ]
show collections
and you see again that the sessions have
been established
and if we say db.sessions.find
we shouldn't find any documents
whatsoever
in this collection so
we have a completely clean slate
and in order to establish a new session
all we have to do is make some sort of
http request
to our application so if i came to the
browser
and i clicked refresh here what's going
to happen
is that session middleware is going to
kind of fire
it's going to create a session and then
what it's going to do
is create a session id which is going to
be stored in a cookie
in this browser so like you know just
like we don't have any
sessions in the database yet we also
don't have any cookies
in the browser yet so let's go back to
our code and what i'm going to do
is just walk you through a few the
options and then we'll finally see
exactly how it's working
so when we set up our session middleware
we have a secret
pretty self-explanatory but this secret
is going to
well usually it's going to be stored in
an environment variable
and you don't want to expose this to the
public
because it basically says if the secret
is invalid then the session is invalid
too but in this case
i just put some secret just so that we
can have it all in front of us
then we have a couple options here
resave and save
uninitialized and these are just options
relating to
what does the session do if nothing has
changed
what does the session do you know if
something has changed
and basically tells the middleware
how to react to different events in the
browser
you can read up on the documentation a
little bit more on these options
but the thing that we're interested in
we already talked about the session
store
but what we're doing is we're setting a
cookie max age
so in other words like we talked about
in a previous video
a cookie can have an expires header and
or not
a header but an expires property which
says
after a certain amount of time the
browser is going to delete the cookie
and it's not going to attach to any of
the requests in the future
so in this case we're setting our cookie
equal to one day
and you can see the math that we're
doing here in the comment
we're basically just saying one day 24
hours in a day
60 minutes in an hour 60 seconds in a
minute and a thousand milliseconds
in a second and so that's the math that
we're doing right here to get to
a full day for that expires property
so basically what's going to happen when
i
send an http get request
to our sole route right here is the
session middleware
is going to initialize a session
and then it's going to take that session
id and set it equal to this
or set the cookie equal to that session
id
the cookie is then going to be put in
the set cookie header
http header and then that is going to
be in the response header it's going to
go in the browser the browser is going
to receive it
and say oh you want me to set this
cookie i'll set the cookie
and now every time we refresh that
cookie will be
a part of that request so let's go ahead
and do this
we're going to visit our only route in
the application
and to do that we need to go to google
chrome
and we're going to click refresh
so when we clicked well now we it did
not load so let me go ahead
and do that one more time we refreshed
it
we get our response it says hello world
sessions
and what you'll notice is now we have
this cookie
which is by default called connect dot
sid
in the express session middleware and we
have some sort of value here which
somehow corresponds to our session id
so basically what's happening is the
express session middleware
is going to get this cookie on every
request
it's going to take the value of that
cookie it's going to say
okay look up this session id in the
session store
which is the database and then it's
going to say is the session valid
if so let's use the information from the
session
to either authenticate our user
find out some data about our user maybe
like how many times that user has
visited
our site anything of that sort
is what's going to happen when the user
loads a different route you'll also see
that we have an expires
property right here that says tomorrow
this cookie is going to delete from the
browser
but for now since it's still valid
it's going to attach to every single
request
so if we go to the network and look at
that last request
we'll see that in the response header
this came from our express server
using the express session middleware
we have the setcookie header and
we set the connect.sid header and we
gave it an
expires now in the request headers
since we only did this once you won't
see any cookie
but if i click refresh one more time
and we look at the request headers and
response headers
you'll see that in the request headers
we have the cookie
that was set previously so in other
words the browser is saying
okay i have a cookie that is still valid
let me attach it to every ques
request within this localhost domain
all right so we have this cookie on
every request now
let's see what's happening on the back
end so let's go back to our code
and we're in the [ __ ] shell so we're
looking at our database right now
and we're going to type in db oh let me
clear this real quick
db.sessions.find
and that's going to look in the sessions
collection for any documents in that
collection
and you'll see that we have one and only
one document
which represents the session that we
just
established in the browser so you'll see
that the id
is right here which you can also see in
that cookie
that we have in the browser so let's see
the first couple letters were
capital a y yj
so let's go back to the browser and
you'll see that the
cookie right here is has got that id
set in it so that's how we kind of
connect the
back end to the front end and then let's
once again come back to our code
so we also have the expires header
within here
so we can also validate it on the back
end and
basically what this is going to do is
every time
the server gets that specific cookie
with that session id
attached to it it's going to come to
this sessions collection in the database
it's going to grab that document out of
the database
or the session store and it's going to
get information
that we have set on to that session and
use it to
do whatever we want to do with our
application
now this is great and all but what do we
actually use this
express session middleware for well
in another video in this passport.js
series
you'll see how passport.js actually
connects in
to the express session middleware and
uses the session
to actually authenticate the user but
since this is kind of a standalone video
i'm not going to get into that all i'm
going to show you before we kind of
conclude
is where this session is being set
now we know that the cookie in the
browser
has the session id and we use that
session id
to look up the session in the database
or the session store
now we can also come to our routes
and get information about the session so
if we said console.log
request dot session
you'll get to see exactly what that
session looks like
and we can actually set properties to
that session
so again i'm connected using nodemon
so we'll automatically refresh when we
save this app so let me click control
s to save you'll see that something
happens here
so we reset and now if we visit this
route again in the browser
in the console we should see the session
object
so let's quickly switch over to the
browser
we'll refresh refresh this page
and then we'll come back to our code
window
and you'll see that our session object
has been printed to the console
right now all we have is a
expires header and a couple other
metadata properties but what we could
also
and this is set to the cookie object but
we could also set other information
so we could set something like how many
visits a user has made to our page
so let's go ahead and do something
really simple like that
in our only route that we have for this
application
let's just say
[Music]
if request dot session
dot view count
we want to say request dot session
dot view count equals
request dot session dot view count
plus one or you could just do the plus
plus syntax
at the end you could just do something
like that and be done with it but
we'll be really explicit here and we'll
set a value
okay so if we have that property on the
session we're going to increment it by
one
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to say in
the response instead of hello world
we're going to say you have visited this
page x amount of time so
we'll use a little javascript syntax
and we need to change these to backticks
to get this to work
and let's see we can just put in
request.session.view
count and now it should tell us how many
times we've visited this page
when we visit that page now we also have
to say
else because in this first occurrence
we're not going to have this property
set
so if that does not exist then we're
going to say request dot session
dot view count equals one
all right so we have set a property to
the session object
and let's go ahead and save this
application
and go to the browser and visit it
so we're in the browser now and we will
reload
and it says you have visited this page
one times
it should be time but now
every time we refresh we're going to get
that number to increment
because of the logic that we've put into
our route
so you can see how this session object
could be very useful
for tracking information about a
specific user or client
one last thing i want to show you if we
go back to the code
you can look it up in the database again
so let's go back to [ __ ]
and let's find that session once more
you'll see we still have just one object
one
document in the database but now we have
this little property down here
so when we set the view count property
on the request.session object that
actually persisted in the session store
or our mongodb database under the view
count property
so again you can see how powerful this
is and you could
also kind of extrapolate out and start
to foreshadow
how something like a passport js
middleware
could kind of connect into this middle
this express session middleware
to keep its own sort of data you came
here to learn user authentication
and it took us about two hours to get to
the part where we're actually
writing it for the first time i hope the
prerequisite lessons that we just
covered were really helpful to get us
set up to this point
and now we're ready to actually
implement the passport local strategy
within your web app
your users are going to have the
expectation
that you have the option to do a
username or email based
authentication you have to have this
because what if your user doesn't have a
google account or a facebook account to
use that
you know other authentication option
that you're offering
you've got to have this most basic
option for them and the passport local
strategy is one way to do it
equipped with our knowledge of http
headers
cookies the express session library and
express middleware we are fully ready to
jump into this strategy
my goal in this video is to get the
passport.js
library imported into our express.js
application and can start to configure
it
to help us with this i've set up a
repository on my github that will
basically give you
a starter template to work from and what
this is going to do
is kind of eliminate all of that stuff
that we don't want to focus on
such as setting up a basic express
application
setting up a very basic database with
mongodb
and even setting up something like a
express
session which we talked about in one of
the prerequisite videos
for this tutorial series in this
repository
i've got three branches but the master
branch is going to have
your starter template so if you don't
know
how to use branches in git that's
totally fine
if you do want to learn more about that
i actually have a full
tutorial series on using git but
anyways you can see if you come into
github
you don't have to actually know any
commands to do this you just drop down
and you can see that the different
branches will have
the final branch is kind of the final
implementation
um no promises that will get you know
line by line
character by character to the same
implementation here
during the video but will come very
close
the overall structure will be exactly
the same
and then we have the final all-in-one
which is basically just one js file or
javascript file
that has everything that you need
to run this with tons of comments so
that you can really figure out what is
going on
so that's what the repository is you can
go ahead and fork it
or clone it whatever you want to do
[Music]
and then download it to your computer
and once you've done that you should
land to a screen
like the one i've got right here
and i've got open the readme which kind
of gives you
basic instructions on how to use it we
went through most of this
already so let's go ahead and close that
out
and take a quick tour of what's going on
in this repository and then we will go
into the configuration
of the passport local strategy let's
take a quick look
at what i've got for you already set up
in the template
application it's pretty similar to what
you probably have seen before i tried to
make it
a similar structure to what you might
find in a lot of
online express node.js tutorials so
hopefully this looks a little bit
familiar
but anyways we start with our app.js
which is going to set up our basic
express app
so the imports at the top let's just go
through them real quick if you haven't
installed them
after cloning the repo just type npm
install to get those installed
we have express pretty straightforward
mongoose which is the odm
for mongodb i will mention
um while we're on this line i've already
got my
[ __ ] d service running
in the background so you'll have to do
that
when you're running this app and i i
don't even know if i have this
in the readme so maybe i will
put that in here right now
we'll just say make sure to run
the mongod service
before running the app locally
all right so now that we got that
covered
just make sure that you have that
running and then you should be able to
run this app
just fine um all right so moving on
we have express session which i've
covered in a separate video
how this works and how to set it up so
i've already implemented it here for you
if you want to learn more about that go
to that video again
that is in the description just click on
the playlist and you'll
you'll find it so next up is passport
this is what most of this video in the
next couple videos is going to be about
will require in the built-in node.js
crypto library which is going to allow
us to
create and verify passwords
we require in the routes which is the
routes folder we'll get there in just a
second
and also we have a database
configuration
in the config directory now coming down
we have [ __ ] store
directly related to the express session
middleware
again that's another video we have
this little line right here most people
probably have seen it but if you haven't
all this is doing is giving us access to
the dot env file that we have defined
over here
that by default is not going to be
imported when you clone this repository
because it's got secret keys in it so
you will need to create the dot
env file and in the
env file i think you only need two
things you need the db string
and the secret and for
my case i'm just using a very simple db
string
i don't even have a user or a password
just to keep things simple for now but
in production you'd obviously want to
um have a user and password in the
actual database that you would connect
to
so and then the secret is going to be i
think for the express session module
so let's close that and then you can see
you can actually get access to those
variables
anywhere within this app.js file
with this syntax the
process.env.variablename
all right so moving on we have the
express application
pretty simple this is some middleware
for parsing
http responses
most of you would probably have seen
app.use
bodyparser.json
but i've just used the built-in express
parsers because i think these actually
came in a little bit recently
in like a recent release i could be
wrong on that
um but you no longer need to use body
parser
all right session setup again this was
covered in a different video but let's
just take a
very very quick look at what is going on
here
we have our session store which is going
to say
hey express session middleware i want
you to use the mongodb
database for the
session storage and
in that i want you to use the sessions
table
or not table but collection in
that mongodb database so that's the
session store
down here in the configuration options
for the session middleware
we are telling it to use that store then
we have some other
options here so the secret we just
talked about that
that's going to help the express session
middleware
validate the session that it has looked
up
it's going to check to see if it matches
that secret
these two options have to do with you
know how does the session treat
or how does the session react when
there's actually no changes
in the browser you can read up about
that on your own
and then finally the cookie this is the
this is also another separate video in
this series
but basically what we're doing is we're
storing the session id
in a cookie in the browser and this
right here
is just going to kind of tell the
express session middleware
hey i want you to it basically set an
expires header
um not header but an expires property
of one day so this cookie will expire in
one day and a new session will have to
be
reestablished when it does expire
alright that was just a quick overview
if you want more you have to check out
the other video
next up we have passport authentication
i've just put in this basic require
statement
to show you where it is so it's in the
config directory we'll get to that
in just a moment we are using our routes
so this is pretty standard in express
you put your routes
after the other middleware but before
your air handler
in this case we don't have an error
handler
you might want to do that for a
production application
finally we are listening on port 3000
localhost pretty straightforward so
that is the basic app let's go ahead and
look at some of
the other pieces so let me save that
we'll first start in the config so we
have passport.js
all i've done here is imported the
relevant modules that we'll will need to
set it up
and then i've imported some database
configurations
uh well the connection and then the user
model that we'll be
um using so going straight over to the
database
configuration this is a pretty standard
mongodb
database setup we're requiring in
mongoose
again we got this access to the env file
we're going to grab the db string from
that file
and we're going to create a connection
with it so we pass in
the string to the create connection
method on the mongoose object
and then we pass in these options which
will just suppress
any warning messages finally
we have a user schema it's very simple
we just have a username hash and salt
you will see
what the hash and salt mean a little bit
later
so we create a model for that user based
on the schema
and we export the connection so that we
can use it in other files
so pretty straightforward with that
let's see what else we've got
we have the password utils which should
just have the
validate password and create password
functions so let's check that out
and you can see that i've already kind
of templated out
what the functions will look like all we
have to do is jump in there and actually
implement them let's see if i'm missing
anything
else okay i've got the routes just one
route file
and i know there's a lot of stuff in
here but really there's
not much of anything
we pass in the express router uh
passport because we're going to actually
use passport in our routes
we have some past password utils we just
looked at the database connection
and user model and really what we're
going to be
doing the only thing we're going to be
doing in this file is these two routes
so the login and register route we're
going to have to implement
the logic behind these in the git routes
below
all i've done is create a super simple
flow that will go through as we
implement this passport authentication
so you'll see the home page is just
going to tell you to please register you
click the link
goes to the register page which is right
here
that has just a really ugly looking form
that we will type a username and
password into to
register that will submit to our custom
implemented post request up here then it
will
if you're successful it will redirect
you i think
to the login page then you will
log in with your username and password
which will
create a post request to the login post
route which we have to implement
and if you successfully log in i think
it will redirect you
we're going to have to write this logic
but it will redirect you to
i believe in the i believe the login
success route
so it'll say you've successfully logged
in
then we'll try to visit a protected
route
and that will be right here and we're
going to check
if we're authenticated and let you in if
you are
so basically you can look at this but
it's just a flow
of pages that we're loading the reason i
did this
without using something like ejs or
another temple
templating language is just to keep it
as simple as possible
all we're doing is passing basic html
and html forms
and using the built-in express
methods like res.send in res.redirect
so hopefully that makes sense if it
doesn't take a look at this for
a few minutes and i know it will before
we get into the actual
implementation and configuration of
passport
i wanted to show you again i know we
already touched on this in the first
video just for a few minutes but
i want to show you how to find the
documentation for this
i personally had a very difficult time
finding kind of an end to end
tutorial and documentation for
passport and i think since all the
strategies
are developed by different developers
there's not really
you know a one size fits all
documentation for it
now if you go to the passport.js website
you'll first find that you can click
strategies
and browse through all the different
strategies you'll be able to go to those
pages
but in our case we're using the passport
local strategy
so if we click this we should be
redirected to the passport local
strategy
it's going to give us some basic usage
instructions
so we install it we configure it with
a verify function and
then we can use it in the route here but
that's pretty much
all that it gives us there's actually a
couple more steps that you need to do
to use the um local strategy
which is kind of weird why it's not in
this on this page
and if you click on the examples it goes
to a 404 page
i think maybe that was recent i don't
know
whatever the case this is actually not
where you're going to want to go
for documentation on the passport local
strategy
the passport local strategy is actually
better documented in the general
documentation of the passport.js
middleware so if you go to documentation
right here
and you click username and password
this is where you're going to get a
little bit more verbose
documentation on the passport local
module
so here we have the same thing install
passport local
but here we're getting a little bit more
detailed
implementation of this verify callback
and how you would use the form how you
would
use it on the route what kind of
parameters you can pass
to the verify callback so this is a
little bit better documentation
but it still kind of misses some of the
configuration that you have to do
for this module so
i'm going to show you exactly how to use
it but
you can kind of peruse the passport.js
documentation
you'll find a few things for example
if we click on configure it's going to
tell us how to configure a strategy
because
being a framework for the middleware
passport has kind of a standardized way
to
integrate different strategies so on
every single strategy that we use we're
going to need
a verify callback so in this section
kind of talks about that verify callback
and what the different responses
are required based on how the user
you know whether the user entered the
correct or incorrect
credentials whether we got an error
message
whatever the case it tells you that and
then we also have documentation on
the authenticate method so passport
actually provides you with a built-in
authenticate method on the passport
object
and all you need to do is provide it
with
the name of the strategy that you've
defined
and then passport figures out how to
go find the verify callback that you've
configured
for that specific strategy i know this
sounds like a lot and i know this
documentation is a little bit sporadic
it's not necessarily you know a b c d
one two three four it's it's a little
bit confusing so
let's just get into the implementation
and i'll do my best to
kind of document the passport local
strategy for you
like we saw in the documentation the
first thing we need to do
is define the verify callback for the
passport local strategy
so we'll do this in the passport config
file
and all we need to do is comment this
out
the passport.use method and pass in
the strategy and the verify callback
so i'm just going to paste in the full
thing real quick
and you'll see that this looks pretty
similar to what we saw in the
documentation
it's also going to be pretty similar to
what you'll see in a lot of tutorials
but i personally find this a bit
confusing when we're looking
at it all at once so let's go ahead and
deconstruct
what's going on in this configuration
put it in some variables so that we know
exactly what's going on all right so the
first thing that we need to do
is define the strategy itself
so let's say strategy
equals and then in this case it's going
to be the new
local strategy all right so that is the
most basic
way to create a strategy and then this
strategy is going to require
that verify callback so let's define
that above here
and the verify callback is going to
take a couple parameters it's going to
take a username
password and done function
in this case down here i just called it
callback
but you it doesn't really matter what
you call this
all you need to know is that this
represents a function that you will
eventually
pass the results of your authentication
to
so those are the parameters and
they will actually be populated by the
passport framework
based on how you implement this so we
expect the username
to be the value that we received
from the request body of some sort of
login form so if we
were to create a login form type in our
username and password
and then make a post request to the
express api
that post request is going to have a
username and password field
and passport is going to automatically
look for those two fields
and grab the values of them and populate
them
in the verify callback now there's a
little bit
tricky part to this because if you don't
name
your username and password fields
exactly this
username and password the passport
um framework is not going to or not the
passport framework but the passport
local strategy
is not going to know what variable to
look for
so in order to prevent this we can
actually define
custom fields that we want passport to
look in
i'll show you how to include this in a
few seconds but first let's just get it
in a variable
so we'll say custom fields
is equal to an object and we'll say the
username
field is going to be
uh you name we're just making this up
making it custom so that we can see
exactly how this works
so our username field is you name and
then our password
field is just going to be something like
pw
so obviously these are some
non-conventional
ways to name the password and username
fields
but if we define them in our custom
fields object
then passport local will know where to
look
alright so we'll use that object in just
a second but first let's come back to
the verify callback
so in the verify callback what we're
doing is
basically our own implementation of a
password verification
now this is where i think people get
tripped up a little bit i know i did
um thinking that the verify callback
has to be a very specific structure
and we have to use a certain database
because of course the documentation
online
shows that we're using the mongodb
database
but in reality it doesn't matter what
database you use
and it really doesn't matter how you
choose to verify
the credentials all that matters is that
the
return values that you pass to this done
callback
are what passport expects
so we can come in here and do whatever
we want but
for simplicity as we know i'm using the
mongodb database so it's going to look
pretty similar to
what you saw in some of the examples so
let's go ahead and copy this
so i think we're done here with this
copy paste
and then we can put it right here
and all we're doing is going to
the mongodb database and we're looking
for a user
that has the username provided in this
parameter
so again what's going to happen we make
a post request
and we provide a json body with
you name and password then passport as a
middleware
is going to look for these two fields
finds them
takes the value and populates these two
parameters with those two values so
at this time when we're executing this
callback
these represent the username and
password so we can look up
the username in the database and then
just in a basic promise we are
returning the user so we check if
there's a user
in the database you know if someone has
actually registered already
then or actually it's the opposite if
there's not a user in the database
then we're just going to return this
should be updated to
done to represent this done callback
up here and what we're telling passport
here
is that no there was not an error in
this
operation but there was also not a user
so
go ahead and reject this and so passport
will return
i believe it's a 401 on unauthorized
http status so that's the first check we
need to do
then um we need to check whether this
is valid sorry for all these comments i
had them in here
before when i was writing this out
so we have a variable here that says is
valid and for right now we don't know
how this works
and this is not even a function that
we've defined yet
but basically what we're doing we can
comment this out for
well let's not comment it out yet what
we're doing
is we're putting the password through
some sort of verification function which
is going to
um or we're also putting the hash in the
salt stored in the
user record in the database and
we're verifying those two things against
the password
you'll see how that works in a minute
but basically
let's just assume that this returns true
or false which it does
and we say if the password if the login
credentials are valid
then we're going to return the callback
let me update this real quick again
these are just corresponding to this
parameter that
passport provides we're going to say
nope there was no
error and yep there was a user and this
user was
successfully authenticated based on my
verification function so when we pass
this to passport
it's going to let us into the route and
then finally
if it's not valid we say nope there is
no error
but we did not verify this user
correctly
don't let them in the route and then
finally
we using the promise syntax we're just
going to catch
any of the errors that happen within the
express application maybe on the
database side of things
and if we get an error we're just going
to pass that to passport and it knows
how to handle that
so that is the basic verify callback
and i'll show you really quickly what is
actually going to happen here
when we use it in a route so let me save
that
and come back to one of our routes
so let's go down to the
um the post login route
so what we're going to do is include a
middleware
in the post login route called
passport.authenticate
and then in the authenticate we're going
to say
um the local strategy
and we're going to pass in um
well we can we can worry about the rest
of this a little bit later
all i wanted to show you here is that
we're passing this middleware in the
login post route
and so basically what's going to happen
is we make a post request to log
in with our username and password
and then that gets intercepted by the
passport middleware
and then we come in passport populates
these two
objects it runs this function so we're
looking up the user in the database
validating the credentials returning
some sort of response
and if we get this response right here
where we populate a user then it's going
to go to the next part of this function
and it lets us in the route so that is
the basic
implementation of passport and now we're
going to tie
up some loose ends and make sure that it
actually works and then we'll see
it run live we just have a few more
things we have to do
to get this working um the first thing
i forgot to do when we finish this up is
actually
complete this verify callback
so we started with passport.views
and then we passed in all of this stuff
so we need to actually do this now
um so the first thing that we need to do
is
let's see we have our custom fields and
our verify
callback so in our new local strategy
we're going to pass in our custom fields
and our verify callback
and then we're going to say passport.use
and then we're gonna pass it in that
local strategy
so now we actually have it configured
and in app.js when we
require it in somewhere
um let's see where do we do this
right here in the passport
authentication we require
in the configuration and what that's
going to do
is basically just take this line right
here
and include it in the app.js
now that we've got our strategy
configured we've done the bulk of the
work
there are a few extra things that we're
going to have to put in here
but i'm going to go ahead and just copy
them in
um and then we're going to come back to
them a little bit later
after we have everything working to
understand them
a little bit better so at the bottom of
this configuration
i'm just going to paste in two
initializations
and this is the passport.serialize user
and deserialize user now this has to do
with the express session
and how we put a user into the session
and grab a user out of the session
basically
what is happening is we're going to put
the user id
into the session and then we're going to
when we want the user to come out of the
session we will grab that user id that
was stored there
and find it in the database
again we're going to come back to this
so don't worry about it if you don't
understand it
i think this these two functions are a
little bit tricky
especially because there's not a whole
lot of documentation around them
so let's save that let me save this real
quick
let's come back to app.js and add in our
last two lines that we're going to need
before all of this is going to work so
right after we require in the passport
configuration
we're going to say app.use
passport.initialize
and again what this is going to do is
kind of initialize the
passport middleware and um
basically so that it doesn't get stale
so we might be using
different routes we might click to
several different routes
and if we don't reinitialize the
passport
middleware then there's a chance that
hey maybe the user
um maybe their session expired or
something
in the time that we're doing that it's
just always safe to
refresh the passport middleware every
single time that we load a route
and so that's what this is doing and
then we need to put in passport.session
which has to do a little bit with
what we just talked about the serialize
and deserialize user
but um more so it has to do with the
actual
express session middleware so i know we
talked about this a little bit
earlier we also talked about it in a
separate video
but the express session gives us access
to
the request.session object and anything
that we
store on the request.session object
inside
any of the routes is going to be
persisted to the database
under the sessions collection so knowing
this
passport cleverly kind of
plugs into that and bootstraps off it
and uses it as a user authentication
mechanism
so we're going to actually go
through this along with the serialize
and deserialize
user in a few minutes but for now let's
see if we've got this working
we still have a few things to do in the
routes before it's going to work
but let's save it and actually run the
app
i'm going to run this with nodemon so we
have live updates
so nodemon app.js
and doesn't look like we have any errors
at the moment so
there is a chance that we have this
working
the first thing that we're going to have
to do before the passport middleware
is going to be effective is finish
defining
the password verification and generation
functions
so if you remember in the passport
configuration
in this verify callback that we had
defined
we called this method called valid
password
but in this module we haven't
actually created this valid password
function
so it's not going to work as it stands
right now
we're going to have to go over to our
password utils file
and define both the valid password and
the gen password
functions before anything's going to
work we're going to open up password
utils
in the lib folder and you'll see that i
have basically templated out
the two functions that we're going to
need but to understand this
i've actually put a slide together so
that you can
visualize which at what's actually
happening with the generate
and validate password functions
we're going to be using the node.js
crypto library to do this
but before we get into the actual like
what methods we're using
it's better to have a conceptual
understanding on the screen right now
is a basic representation of
how we generate and validate a password
to
a database now the cardinal rule here
is that you're never going to store a
plain text password in a database
that's kind of web application 101
i think everyone is pretty familiar with
that but
actually figuring out how to do that is
a little bit more complicated
now we talked about earlier how the
passport.js
middleware does not give you a
specific way that you need to do this it
gives you a lot of freedom
as to how you might generate and
validate
the passwords that the users are
providing
in the login and register forms as we go
through this
just note that this is not the only way
that you can
go through this process there are other
libraries
other than the node.js built-in crypto
library
there's also different types of logic
that you can go through
but i've tried to keep it as standard as
possible and kind of
in line with what you would call best
practice
so anyways what's going on here is we
have two steps
in the process so we have the creation
of the password
and the verification of the password you
can think of this
as the register and the login so
you're sitting there behind your
computer you found this cool new web app
and the first thing that the web app is
going to ask you to do is register
you need to give them a username and a
password and then
maybe a couple other things like an
email
first last name maybe even an address or
something
but what's important is that you are
providing
that web app with a plain text password
you're just typing that into a field and
when the web app receives that password
it is still
in plain text form we can't really avoid
that
that's fine but what happens is we need
to transform that
into something that we can actually
store securely
in the database without worrying about
some hacker
you know taking over a database and
grabbing
all the you know users passwords in that
database
once the user information is stored in
the database we can move on to step two
which is password verification now in
step two you can think of this
as the login process so when the user
sits behind their computer
and is typing in their username and
password to log into your web app
that's going to be the verification step
and what's going to happen is they're
going to provide you
with their username which you're going
to take
and you're going to look up that user in
your database
using the username or maybe an email
once you find that user in the database
then you're going to have access
to this password hash and the salt that
we stored before
so you're going to pull both of those
values out
and along with the password the plain
text password that the user just
provided you
you're going to put those values through
the same exact hash function
so you pull the salt out of the database
from that user
and you put in the plain text password
that they just typed in
and so in this case we have the same
exact
values for these parameters as we did
when we created the hash
in the beginning and we know since a
hash function
is always going to give you the same
exact value
if you put the same parameters into it
we know that we can
generate a password hash and compare it
to the hash that we stored in the user
record in the database
and if those two values match then we
know
that we have validated this user and
that they have entered the correct
credentials
we've got a conceptual understanding of
this process so let's go ahead and
code it we're going to come back to vs
code
again i've set up the functions in the
parameters that they require
right here and we're going to start with
the generate password function
which is the step one of the process
so this password argument is going to
come from the user when they type
their password into the register form
and then here is our implementation
now i'm going to walk you through this
um we're using the node.js crypto
library
and the first thing that we're going to
do with that is
generate a salt which is just a
pseudorandom value
and it's going to add a bit of
randomness to
our generation of the hash
so we have the salt then
we pass in the plain text password
and that salt to the pb kdf2
method on the crypto library and then
this last part sync just means
synchronous
for synchronous operation and then the
10
000 right here is going to represent how
many iterations we're doing
64 is how long or how big this hash is
going to be
and then right here we specify which
hashing function we're going to use
finally we will convert this to a
hexadecimal string
now down here we just return those two
values
and we are done with this piece of the
implementation
to learn a little bit more about what we
just did
i'm going to pull up a document on
google this is from the internet
engineering task force
and it's just basically a specification
for different
cryptography methods and
or password-based cryptography methods
and if we go down
to the table of contents we can actually
find
the pbk
specification which is what we were
using from the node.js crypto library
and you'll see that this is actually
going to
well we might actually be in the wrong
spot here we're in the appendix
see if we can get somewhere a little bit
more straightforward
okay we clicked on the wrong one here so
we need to click on 5.2
and this is going to show you kind of
the template for
implementing that kind of function so
the node.js crypto library
is just implementing this standard right
here
and we can actually come up and see some
information about it
so i think there's something on
iteration count
it says that they recommend at least a
thousand
we put in well you want to have 10
million
for a super secure implementation we are
somewhere in the middle with 10 000
which should be fine and then it also
talks a little bit
about the salt up here and you can read
up about
what that actually is a lot of this is
just math so i don't want to get into it
but this is kind of where the standard
comes from so we're not just using some
random crypto function
this is kind of what the engine internet
engineering
task force has designated as this is how
you should do it when
you are verifying and generating
passwords
we can now come back and do the second
function
which is the valid password
i'm not really sure why i called it
valid password probably should be
validate password
but anyways here is the implementation
for that
all we're doing it this is basically the
same exact thing
remember what we went through on the
slide we're just
creating the same exact hash that we did
up here except this time we're receiving
the hash
and the salt or well we're just passing
the salt
but we're getting that salt from the
user record in the database
and then we're getting this password
when the user types
it in in the login form so given the
same
inputs we should expect the same output
and therefore we are going to return
whether the hash that comes from the
database is equal to the hash that we
computed using the password that the
user just provided us
in the salt that was in the database for
that user record
so we're going to either receive true or
false and this
is what we're going to put in our
passport js
verify callback so let's save this
and come back to our passport js
configuration and you'll see that we're
already using this right here we've
already set it up how we want to
we just need to import it so i'll do
that right now
so we'll say valid password equals
require
lib password utils dot
valid password because we've exported
them
here at the bottom so now our
passport.js
implementation is complete and it should
work
with our application once we
implement the two post routes for login
and register so let's do that right now
we'll come to the routes and you'll see
that we have the login and register
routes
they're not implemented yet so we need
to do that
it's pretty simple so i'm just going to
paste in the implementation
most of this is just creating
a user record in the database but we're
also going to be
implementing that first part the gen
password function
in this register route i think i have it
yep i have this already imported but
let's go ahead and rename it we'll just
say gen password to stay consistent
and then we need to grab the gen
password function off of
the import so now that we have that we
can
implement this so here's the
implementation
we'll walk through it really quickly i
want to point out a few things
before we get started we are grabbing
the
password and username values from the
request.body.pw
in unname fields if you remember from
the passport configuration
just to demonstrate the options you can
do we went ahead and customized
what we're expecting to see from that
request.body object
so we need to stay consistent and we
need to use those
to grab those values so you can see what
we're doing here is we are
generating that salt hash object so it's
just an object
with the salt in the hash so this one
right here
and that's coming from the gen password
function
that we just imported up here from the
password utils
then we are going to create a new
user object for the database we're going
to save that user
we'll go ahead and just console log it
to the terminal
and then we are going to redirect to the
login route
all right so we have implemented
register and we can go ahead
and try that out in the browser so let's
run it
run the application looks like we don't
have any errors so let's jump back to
the browser
type in localhost 3000
slash register or actually we can just
go to the home page
and it gives us a link to the register
we're going to enter our username
and our password i'll just do one two
three to keep it simple
and we'll submit it looks like it
properly
did something let's come back to the
terminal to verify that
good news we see the object that we just
created
we put the username in there and then
the hash and the salt
that we got from the gen password
function
and then we can also check the database
so let me just open the [ __ ]
shell and we'll look it up so
show databases
we are using the tutorial db based on
the dot env file
so i will say use
tutorial db and then
we can say db dot
users dot find and you should see
the user that we just created
so clearly we've got the user in the
database and the last thing that we need
to do
in this entire flow is implement the
login route
so if we come back to what we're already
in the file
we have the login route that we've
already kind of put this
passport.authent method in a little bit
earlier
but i just want to add a few things to
it
and we'll actually simplify this a
little bit as well
the first thing i'm going to do is pass
in a second
argument to the authenticate method and
this is just going to be an
object that tells passport where to
redirect
based on the status of the login
so if you remember the
passport.authenticate method
is literally just going to look in the
passport configuration
for this verify callback and it's going
to
call this function right here and
this is going to return either a user
if we are validating the user correctly
and the user has provided the correct
password
or we're going to say false and in that
case
it's going to redirect to the login
failure
so really since we're adding conditions
for both
a success and a failure we don't need
this last
function right here so we've just
included this
normal callback that we see in most
express routes
but we don't need that in this
implementation
and we are pretty much done with the
login
post request so let's save this and give
it a try
in the browser we'll type in the
same user that i did earlier one two
three
for the password and submit
and it says that we have successfully
logged in so something worked here
now we can go to the protected route it
says you are authenticated
we can log out and reload now we're not
authenticated
and we can log in again so we can just
go in this circle here
it's kind of how i set it up so that we
can see that flow
but i'm going to be talking a lot more
about how this is actually
working and how you can use the passport
middleware
in your routes in the next video
but let's come back one more time to the
code
and just kind of take a look at the
routes that we just went through
so we started at login
login submitted the
data that we put in there and the
passport verify callback
was called we successfully
validated the user so we got to right
here
and then we come to the route the login
post route
and we had a success so
we are going to come to the login
success route
you can see this success redirect login
success
so we'll come down here
somewhere so we came to the login
success
then it said go to the protected routes
we clicked that link
and we came right here which you'll see
a little bit of extra syntax
we're going to go through this in the
next video but this is how
we would authenticate the user once
we've
run through that authentication flow in
the login post route
and then we can also log out so we've
got a logout method
on the request object and then
the cycle kind of repeats
we are officially done with the passport
configuration
we've got it working completely and this
is all you're going to have to do for
the passport local strategy
to authenticate users into your web app
now i did mention earlier that we were
going to come back to something
and it was in the passport configuration
here at the bottom
so these two methods the
passport.serialize and deserialize
and then also i think in app.js
we have these two lines the initialize
in session now we don't really know how
those are working
and i promise that we'll come back and
explain how those are working and kind
of see it
for ourselves in code i would also like
to go through
some of these things like request that
log out
and request that is authenticated and
understand what
is going on there and also kind of
understand
you know you would intuitively think
well we're probably just going to use
the passport dot authenticate
middleware on every single route that we
want to authenticate
but that's not the case for the passport
local strategy
so to start what we're going to have to
understand
is that passport.serialize and
deserialize
configurations so if we open up the
passport
file it's these two configurations
right here that we need to understand to
really grasp
what passport is trying to do in order
to understand this
a little bit better i'm going to open up
app.js
and we're going to write a very basic
middleware
that is just going to give us it's not
going to do anything but it's going to
give us a little bit of debugging power
so we've got these middlewares working
so here's where we set up the session
so we include that here then we include
the passport.initialize
and passport.sessionmiddlewares right
here so after those have done their work
these are happening on every single
route request
we'll put in our custom middleware so
we'll say app.use
and we're going to pass in a simple
function
we're just going to give it the standard
parameters and then what we're going to
do
in the body of it is just console.log
request dot session and
then we will console.log
request dot user so
you'll see how this works the express
session
is going to create this object right
here and the passport middleware
should create this object here and then
finally we have to call next
so it doesn't crash our routes but
basically
every time we visit any route in this
application
this is going to run and we're going to
see exactly how it's working
so for starters let's just get this
running
and visit in in the browser so we'll
come to google chrome
we'll come back to what i've got on the
screen here in a second
[Music]
let's just go to the base route so we're
at the home page
and you can see in the application here
is
our cookie that we've set which
represents the
express session id so that will
we're going to just delete this really
quick so that we refresh
everything so now we have a clean slate
and the express session middleware is
going to recreate a new session
for us to use when we press refresh
so we pressed refresh it created a new
session
and in the console we should see that
printed out
because of the middleware that we just
wrote right here
so you see the session is going to show
us the cookie
and that's pretty much it you'll notice
that the
request.userobject is undefined right
now
and that is because we haven't yet
authenticated our user
using the passport.authenticate method
so let's do that really quickly in the
browser
so we need to actually just visit the
login route
because we've already got this user in
the database
if you remember from last video so we
will sign in
and click submit and this is the same
session id
come back to the code and this time
we've got a different story so this time
let me expand this so we can see it
so here was our
first go around so this is what it
printed
and then this is the second time so
now we have the session with the cookie
but we
also have this line right here and
this was created by the passport
middleware
and when we executed the
passport.authenticate
method which is in the
login post route so right here that's
what we just did
and what passport did behind the scenes
was create this additional property
on the express session and
how we got this right here is through
the passport.serialize
user function so right here
we ran the serialize user function we
passed in the user id
and we stored it under the user property
so let's go ahead and check
to see if this is the actual id of our
user
so it's 5e0f now let's go over to the
[ __ ] shell
and we're already set up to query this
so we'll say
db.users.find
and you'll see that we have the 5e0f
user in the database so the serialize
user function
when we did the passport.authenticate
method
is going to grab that user from the
database
get the id of the user and then insert
that
into the passport.user
or actually it would be the
request.session.passport.user
property so now when
we need to grab this user from the
the session we're going to use the
deserialize user function
so we're kind of seeing it all at once
but
to populate the request.user
right here this is the middleware that
we just wrote to
print all this stuff to the terminal in
order to populate the request.user
we are going to grab the user from the
database
right here and based on the user id that
was provided
in the session object and then we are
going to
attach the found user
to the request.user object
so that was a mouthful and we've got
a few more pieces to this puzzle
so we'll come to app.js and
these two lines are playing into this
equation as well
so when we say passport.initialize
that's going to kind of re-run
everything that we just did
and then the passport.session is going
to kind of work in the same way
so every time we load a route
these two middlewares are going to work
together
and what they're going to basically do
is they're first going to check
to see if this user property is not
null so it would look something like
this
we would say if
request.session.passport.user
not equal to null then we are going to
know that there is a logged in user and
we're going to
grab this user id from
that property then once we grab that
user id from the property
we're going to use the deserialize user
method
pass in oops pass in the user id
grab it from the database and then what
we're going to do
is populate the request.user
and set it equal to whatever user we got
from the database
so that's basically what is happening on
every single route request
now if this user object is null
then that means that the user is not
currently logged in
and we do not grab the user from the
session
and this property request that user is
not
populated if we go in the browser and we
do the log out function or we visit the
logout route
you're going to notice the next time
that we console.log
these two properties that this user
object is not going to exist
so let's scroll to the scroll to the
bottom save this
um come up here so we're at the bottom
let's go to the browser and
first we've got to visit the protected
route and when we click this button
right here
it's going to log us out so we click log
out
and reload and come back to the terminal
and now you'll see that this passport
object
is going to not have this user property
in other words we are not logged in
now you might say okay this is a lot to
look at
and it's a lot of kind of funky logic to
go through every time we want to figure
out
if our user is logged in or not and
luckily
we have some methods built onto this
request
object to kind of do this logic for us
these methods were defined by the
passport middleware
or the passport local middleware and we
can see this
if we visit the repository so
this module the request.js module is
where this is going to kind of happen
or where these are defined and you'll
see a couple
properties attached to the request
object
so the first one is the login property
and
this is actually called
by default when we use the
passport.authenticate method
so we don't really have to ever use this
on our own
if we're using the passport.authenticate
method
now what's useful to us is the last
three properties
so first we have request.logout
so anytime that we want to log our user
out
we just call this method and you'll see
that i do this
when we had clicked that logout button
you'll see in the route for the log out
route
somewhere down here so here's my logout
route and you can see that i have called
that method right there which is
basically going to delete
the
request.session.passport.userproperty
from the session so that's all that
that's doing and then next time
we call the passport.initialize and
passport.sessionmiddlewares
which happens on every route it's going
to check that property
see that it's null and pretty much
declare that the user has been logged
out
all right so the next one we have is the
request
dot is authenticated and this is a
really common one we're going to use a
lot
and basically all this is doing is what
we went through
manually and there's a bunch of funky
code here because it's part of the
framework
but basically all this code is doing
is saying does the
request.session.passport.userpropertyx
property
and is in it is not
null and if that is the case then we
declare that the user
is authenticated because the only way
that that
property would have been populated is
after we use the passport.authenticate
method
which is going to run the verify
callback
which is going to implement our custom
login
logic finally we have request that is
unauthenticated i don't really use this
it's just the opposite
of the request that is authenticated so
you can use it but
it's not really all that complicated
so we've got these methods unfortunately
these are not documented very well
in the passport documentation which is
kind of a shame but
anyways let's come back to our code
and see how we might use these
properties to our advantage
so right now in our routes we are
manually calling these things
and right here we are manually
checking whether the request is
authenticated
and then if it is we are doing something
if it's not we're doing something else
so in order to streamline this a little
bit
it would make a little bit more sense if
we included this
as middleware and all we're doing
is checking if the user is authenticated
and if the user is authenticated we just
call the next
callback and it goes into the route and
if the user is not
authenticated we return some sort of
401 unauthorized error so to make our
lives a lot easier
let's go in the routes folder you can
really put this anywhere
i'm just going to put it in the routes
folder and we'll just say
off middleware.js
and in the off middleware js
i'll just take you through two different
middlewares that we could implement
you can get as creative as you want with
this
but here are some pretty standard ones
that you might use
so we'll say module.exports
dot is off
equal to a middleware function
so there's the standard middleware
parameters or arguments
and then we're going to do something in
here to check whether the user is
authenticated and if they're not we're
going to return some sort of 401
unauthorized error the second one we're
going to do
[Music]
module dot exports dot
is admin so currently
we don't have an admin property
on our user schema but we could
easily add that and we could use this
middleware to basically check
whether the user is logged in and
is an admin so that can help you kind of
protect
routes that are for admins only versus
regular users we'll get to that in a
second but first let's get this
one done so all we're going to do is use
that request
dot is authenticated method that is
attached
from the passport middleware so we'll
say if
request dot is authenticated
then we're going to just say
next and pass it on to the next
middleware
in the chain if the user is not
authenticated
we'll just return a 401 unauthorized
error so we'll just say
res dot status 401
dot json and we'll just
put in a message that says you are
not authorized to view this
resource all right so that's pretty
simple
so if they're authenticated if they're
logged in
we're going to just pass it on to the
next
middleware in the chain if not we're
going to just stop it right there
and return an unauthorized error
all right so let's test this out so we
have the is off
middleware if we come to our route
let's do this let's kind of refactor
this
so in our protected route we're going to
return res.send
you made it to the route
so something to indicate to us that we
successfully made it into the route and
within this route we could do whatever
we want we could return some sort of
data
and to do this we will just pass in
is off as the middleware right there
and of course we need to import this at
the top of this file
so we will say is off
equals require off middleware
dot is off
all right so we've got this set up and
now
if we try to visit the
protected route we should hopefully see
you made it to the route so let's try
that
go to google chrome and we're already at
our protected route
so oh it looks like we are not
authenticated right now because we had
logged out so let's
log in really quick
so we are logged in and when we click go
to protected route we should see that
message that we just
put there it said you made it to the
route so our middleware
is working now let's visit the logout
route
so that we can log ourselves out and
then see if that
other status is going to work so
now we went to the log out route
and we were redirected to the protected
route i'm
not exactly sure how that worked but we
got the error message that we were
expecting and if we were using
you know a front end we could kind of
process
this error in a clean manner and give a
friendly message to the user
so we've got our middleware working and
now
all we have to do is pass in
this short variable before any route
that we want to protect
so the next thing is just kind of an
added bonus
it's not necessary for all applications
but it's something that kind of just
stretches your creativity a little bit
it gets you thinking
outside of the box and we're not just
constrained by
some framework that tells us that we
need to do it this way
so in order to implement the
is admin we are going to come to
the database and add one more thing
to this user schema so we're going to
add an admin property
which is going to be a boolean and
we'll save that and then we need to
actually register a new user
so that they have this admin property
and we'll just by default put
this new user as an admin um
let's see where that happens is going to
be
in the register route
um where are we okay so right here is
where we're going to do this
currently we're just passing in this
data
but i'm just going to hard code in the
admin property
and we're going to say true so save that
we will come back to the browser
and we need to go to the register route
so let's go to register let me get rid
of this and
i'm going to say zack 2
and we'll do the same password one two
three just so i don't forget it
submit we have put this user in the
database
let's go ahead and check that just
really quickly to make sure
so we'll come to the [ __ ] shell
db.users.find
now we have two users in the database
let's kind of extend this
and the second user zac2 has an
admin property of true so
zack the original zach is not an
admin because we haven't added that
property
the second one is an admin so the first
user
should be able to visit an admin route
while the second should not
so let's test that out really quickly we
need to make a route that will
actually test it so let's come down to
protected route
just copy that and
instead of protected we'll say admin
route
so the first thing we want to check is
the is off
we kind of have some freedom how we want
to do this
i'm going to go ahead and simplify
things and just
say is admin so we don't have to repeat
it
so we could do is off and then is
admin and in the in in
this middleware all we have to do is
check whether that property exists
but i'm going to go ahead and simplify
that you'll see what i mean in a second
so we'll say is admin we need to
import that here at the top so
i know this is you know not really good
coding practice we could refactor this a
little bit
but we'll do it just for the sake of
time so we've
put the is admin middleware in there
we've included it in the admin route
and we'll say you made it to the
admin route if they successfully make it
through that
middleware gate so now we come back to
the auth middleware
and let's just copy the same exact thing
except this time we're going to say
if request dot is authenticated
and request.user.admin
since this is a boolean property we can
just say this
so now we have two requirements to get
through
this authentication middleware and then
we have the same
exact um logic here maybe we'll change
the message to say
you are not authorized to view this
resource
because you are not an
admin all right so we've got this
set up and i think we should be able to
visit the route that we just
created so admin route let's just
manually type that
into here and since we haven't
i don't think we've logged in with
anyone yet so let's log
in with the first user so this one
should not be an admin
and we'll go to the admin route
and it'll say you are not authorized to
view this because you're not an
admin as we would expect now let's log
this user out
by just going to log out
and then let's go to login
we're going to log in that second user
that does have
admin privileges
oh looks like we had some sort of login
failure
maybe i just typed it in wrong um oh
it was because i put the wrong username
in so it's not zac one it is zach2
and one two three all right we are
successfully logged in
let's go to the admin route and this
time we should get
a success message you made it to the
admin route
so we've covered a good amount here but
hopefully this kind
of opens up your creativity
into understanding how the passport
local strategy works
how we can use it to creatively
authenticate and allow access to
different resources
based on whether a user is logged in or
logged out
based on whether a user has admin
credentials
and you could even go through some more
complex logic
if you wanted to by creating different
types of middlewares
i know it seems like we've already run a
marathon just trying to get the
passport local strategy implemented but
again authentication user authentication
is not an easy subject i think we kind
of
treat it as an easier subject because
it's like okay there's only a few moving
parts here
it seems like on the surface but once
you get into the implementation there
are so many different things that you
have to understand
in order to debug and have
a solid grasp around user authentication
i want to take a minute to say congrats
there's been a lot of content so far and
you have finally
implemented your first official you know
user authentication scheme where you
actually know what's going on behind the
scenes
you can walk away from this tutorial
right now if you want to
but there is a second part to all of
this
which is the jwt based authentication
that i think
is super super important to know and
it's probably one of the more
popular ways to do it as i mentioned in
the first you know a few minutes of this
video
but as we saw with passport local
strategy having all of these
prerequisites
we also have some prerequisites for
implementing a jwt
authentication strategy in this section
we're going to be tackling
one of those prerequisites which is
public key cryptography
now i will make the disclaimer that to
implement the passport jwt strategy
or a jwt strategy in general you don't
need
public key cryptography in reality you
could very well just use
a symmetric cryptography scheme which is
basically where you just
make a long secret string and store that
in an environment variable
and then use that to you know
authenticate through jwt
now i chose public key cryptography over
something like
you know symmetric secrets because
of a couple reasons number one i think
it's really cool
um public key or asymmetric cryptography
is a really fascinating subject and it's
also kind of the basis
of bitcoin in a lot of those
cryptocurrency systems
so not only are you getting an education
on user authentication but you're
getting
a basic education on how
cryptocurrencies work as well
and the second reason is this is
arguably more robust of a solution than
a basic secret key
but in all reality if you're still
watching this course then you're
probably the type of person
that would be interested in these extra
little details so
let's go ahead and dive into a basic
introduction to public key cryptography
this is a widespread topic public key
cryptography
and cryptography in general can be used
for
several different things whether you're
talking about user authentication
cryptocurrency or even just secure
transport
over https so
i'm going to in this video be talking
about
what is public key cryptography and how
does it work from both a conceptual
and practical level so we're going to
walk through the basics of
you know conceptually how it works but
we're also going to
look at some code and see it in action
before i get into what public key
cryptography is
we need to distinguish between two terms
so that would be asymmetric and
symmetric
cryptography so public key cryptography
what you see on the screen
is a form of asymmetric cryptography
because you have a public and a private
key associated with it
now a more basic form in what is used
for tls or transport secure layer or
whatever
i think that's what it is otherwise the
protocol that we use
to transport data securely over an
insecure internet channel that is going
to be symmetric cryptography
and is identified by a single key
so a great way to think about this is
maybe in a classroom setting so say
you're sitting in a classroom
and you want to pass a secure note to
some of you know one of your friends
across the room
but you want to make sure that if the
teacher intercepts that
message they can't read it so what you
would do
is before class you're going to connect
with your friend or friends that will be
basically interchanging notes and you
need to come up with a secret
key so you might just come up with a
real simple secret key
and that key is going to be okay we're
going to take
every letter in the message and we're
going to
increment it by two so an a
becomes a c and then to decrypt it
you just have to take that c and bring
it
down two letters to be an a so
now that the people that are
interchanging messages know what the
secret key or the cipher algorithm
is they can easily read what the teacher
thinks is gibberish
when the notes are passed so to encrypt
the data
one student is going to basically you
know
write something down write the message
that they want and then they're going to
transpose it using the cipher algorithm
so once again an a becomes a c
a b becomes a d and so forth then
they'll have someone you know walk that
note across the class or pass it from
desk to desk
and we'll say that the teacher
intercepts it the teacher cannot figure
out what the note says it just looks
like gibberish
but the student on the other end could
have decrypted that message
by using that secret cipher
so that is what we call symmetric
cryptography
and obviously we need to protect that
secret now this is again used in
transporting messages over the internet
it's also
used a lot in web application
development
you'll commonly see something called a
secret key
and that is what you'll be using to
encrypt some sort of data
now on the other side of things we have
public key or asymmetric
cryptography which is a little bit more
complicated
and involves a private and a public key
pair
so these private and public key pairs
are mathematically linked
as we'll see a little bit later in this
video
but the basic gist of it is if you have
a public key you can give this to anyone
as long as you keep the private key
secret and
then we can do two things with that
public private key pair
the first use case is going to be
exactly what we just talked about
with encrypting some sort of data so
you might think of this the way that i
like to think of it
is a padlock and a key so basically
i mean this is kind of a contrived
example but basically think about
maybe we're sitting in that same
classroom and we have
some sort of lock box and so one student
is going to write a note which is just
going to be in plain text
and they're going to put the note in the
lock box so
what they'll do now is they will
close the lock box and lock it with
a padlock so that padlock
before class was actually given to the
student by
another student who actually owns the
key to the padlock so just to level set
here
the student that's writing the message
has the public key
of the other student who will eventually
receive that message
and decrypt it with the private key that
corresponds to that public key
so in other words student writes the
message puts it in the box
locks it with the other students
public key then we send the box across
the room
we'll say the teacher intercepts it
tries to open it but of course
they don't have the private key that
corresponds to that padlock
or just the physical key that will
unlock it
so they can't unlock it can't see the
message but if it gets to the student
who does have that private key
they can just unlock the padlock open
the box and see the message
so that is your first use case now the
second use case
is a little more complicated and we're
not going to be able to understand it
in the form of the classroom setting
we're going to have to get into a little
bit more complicated math
but that second use case is called a
digital
signature or identity verification
and this comes in handy when we're
talking about
user authentication and is pretty much
the entire reason
for me making this video so again
if you're following along the
passport.js user authentication series
what you're going to want to really
focus on in this video is that second
use case
or identity verification as you'll see
to use these two use cases all we're
going to do
is change which key we are encrypting
and decrypting with
so to encrypt some sort of data
but not protect an identity we're going
to encrypt with the public key
and decrypt with the private key as with
the padlock
and key in the classroom now the second
use case
we're just going to flip that we're
going to encrypt with the private key
and decrypt decrypt with the public key
now in order to understand this we have
to
understand what a trapdoor function is
and this comes in several different
forms but in the case
of public key cryptography or asymmetric
cryptography we're talking about
elliptic curve multiplication
we'll get to that in one second but
first let's just
generally understand what a trapdoor
function is
so basically what a trapdoor function is
is a one-way
function that takes some pretty big
piece of data
and compresses it into a deterministic
small piece of data outcome so in other
words
we can have an infinitely large piece of
data we could have
let's say something as simple as what
you see on the screen right now
or we could have something as big as
maybe an entire
book and what we can do is we can take
that infinitely large or small data
and put it through what we call a trap
door function
in this case we're using a sha 256 hash
function
and that will always create
a deterministic
outcome so it's going to be the same
length i think it's
i don't remember off the top of my head
exactly how many bytes this
is but it's a hexadecimal representation
of the data on the left so if we were to
come to an
online sha 256 hash
calculator i've pasted in that exact
value
in json string form and we get out this
hash
value and so anytime we put this
particular data into this sha-256 hash
function
we're going to get the same exact output
every single time
so it is deterministic you can try it
for yourself
now we also have to know about this that
we cannot go backwards
so from this data on the right there's
no
possible way that we can derive
what the original data was in the first
place
even though we know that we're using the
sha-256
hash function we know that that's only
one way you can't go the other way
the last important thing to recognize
about this
is we have an infinite number space
essentially now it's obviously not
actually infinite but there are so many
different combinations
that the sha-256 hash function can
produce
that the chances of us having
two different pieces of data that come
to the same hash
value is essentially impossible
now there's plenty of stack overflow
questions on this
and you can read up on them on your own
time
but basically the probability of this
guarantees that we're always going to
get a unique hash value
what we're interested in when it comes
to public key cryptography or asymmetric
cryptography
is a one-way function or trapdoor
function called
elliptic curve multiplication now it's
not actually multiplication
it's a cryptographic function and
basically all we need to know about this
is that it mathematically links the
private and public key
so in other words using the using the
private key
we can derive the public key but
having the public key we can never get
back to that private key
so in other words we can share the
public key with
anyone in the world and they'll never be
able to figure out
what private key corresponds to that
public key
this again is useful for those two use
cases
of either protecting some sort of data
or verifying an identity
we'll see a little bit more how this
works when we actually get into the code
but first let's kind of take a quick
glance at
how elliptic curve multiplication works
so on the right you'll see the elliptic
curve graph
which is useful to us because given
any point on kind of the on this graph
we can take the tangent of that point
and get to another point on the graph
so say we're right here on the graph
well this curve extends
infinitely so we can just take the
tangent all the way up to that curve
so let's go to the next slide and first
start out with what we call
the generator point now the generator
point is an arbitrary
random value or coordinate that we will
always start with
now this point in many cases is going to
be a fixed point that we use
for a large private key
i guess you could say number space so we
always
start with the same generator point but
then
the variable in the quick equation is
the private key
and we take that private key and we
multiply
the generator point by the value of the
private key
so again the private key is some
infinitely well not infinitely but it's
some
small or large value and so we can
just like we can take g times two and g
times three
we can also to do g times you know
10 trillion or whatever the total value
of that private key is
now you might ask how are we going to
multiply
g that doesn't make any sense this is
a graph and how are we going to actually
do multiplication
well the way that that works in elliptic
curve multiplication
is by drawing tangents as we talked
about
so you start with the generator point
and say that your private keys
value is two now obviously
it's never going to be two it's going to
be a much much
larger number and we're going to do this
process many more times but essentially
what's happening
is we start with g we draw the tangent
to that point on the curve which
the tangent intersects this other point
on the curve
then from that other point we say okay
what is the
opposite side of the curve so we draw
this completely vertical
dotted line to get to this last point on
the curve
and that is essentially the
multiplication
value of our operation so
g times 2 is going to equal this
coordinate down here
at the bottom so you can see how this is
kind of it's not exactly the
multiplication that we're used to
but essentially what is happening is we
start with this arbitrary generator
point
we multiply or we go through this
process
however many times the public or the
private key value is
and eventually we will reach a certain
point
on the elliptic curve and that is going
to
represent our public key now
we cannot get back to the private key
based on the public key coordinate but
what we can do
is we can derive that the
private key that may be signed a message
corresponds to the public key so if we
so in other words what you need to
understand is that
using the complex math the elliptic
curve cryptography does
we can actually verify that a public key
corresponds to a given private key
mathematically
without revealing the private key to the
person trying to verify it
so in other words we can decrypt a
message
using a public key you'll see how this
applies a little bit later in the video
just to recap before we get into the
actual code
if we want to do data encryption we're
going to
encrypt with the public key and decrypt
with the private key
if we want to do identity verification
or a digital signature
we are going to take the message that we
want to sign
and we are going to essentially sign it
with our private key
and then some random party you know some
receiver of the message
is going to have somewhere the public
key that corresponds to the private key
and using that public key as we just
talked about
we can use that elliptic curve algorithm
to verify that yes indeed the person who
signed it
has the private key that corresponds to
that public key
okay so let's take a look at the actual
code that will create this private and
public key pair
now there's of course command line
utilities that you can use to do this
but i wanted to kind of write it out so
that we can explain it and understand it
a little bit better
let's go to vs code real quick and
create a new file we're just going to
call this create
keypair.js we'll open up this file
and i'm going to paste in some code that
i already wrote
so let's walk through this code really
quick we're using
the built-in nodejs crypto library
and then the built-in node.js file
system so that we can
output the keys in this directory and
you'll see what's happening
is we have a single function that will
generate a key pair
all it's doing is using the crypto
library to generate the private and
public key
using that elliptic curve multiplication
under the hood
and then we're going to write that
private and public key to
separate dot pem files in the current
directory
so you'll see that here is where the
magic is actually happening
and then down here is where we're taking
those values and writing them to the
files
so you can see that we're using the
rsa algorithm to generate the keys
that's a pretty standard algorithm to
use
and then these you can just go ahead and
look at them
on your own if you want to pause the
video to see what they represent
but basically this is all the math that
we just talked about
and when we run this script by saying
node create key pair it's going to
finish
and then you'll see on the left we have
both
a private key and a public key in other
words
this private key is something that we
want to keep to ourself
not share with anyone and the public key
can be shared with
absolutely anyone with full confidence
that they will never be able to figure
out
what this private key is all right
now that we have our private and public
key let's go ahead and use that in both
of those two
use cases that we talked about earlier
so to do this
just remember we have the private key
and public key saved in this current
working directory
so i'm going to close them i'm going to
close the create key pair
and then i'm going to create a new file
called
encrypt.js and in this new file
we're going to write an encryption
formula where we take some sort of data
and we encrypt the data and we protect
that data
so i'll paste in the code you're going
to see we require
the crypto library again and then i've
got a single function
that's going to take a public key and a
message
as an argument so again if we want to
protect data but not an identity we
encrypt with the public key and decrypt
with the private key
so what this file is going to do is
it's going to take the message that we
give it it's going to create
a node buffer with utf-8 formatting
from that message and then it's going to
pass that buffer
into the built-in public key encrypt
function that the node crypto library
provides us with
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to export this function so that we
can import it into
another module so now that we have this
we can save it and then create one more
file called main.js
where we're going to do a lot of the
work let's go ahead and open up
main.js and copy in some code
that i already wrote a little bit
earlier so again we're using the file
system
and then we're also importing this file
right here that we just wrote
so by importing this we have access to
the encrypt
with public key function and so what
we're going to do in the main file
is we're going to first get access to
the public key that we created
and stored in that pem file in the
current working directory
so we just use the file system to do
that and then
what we're going to do is create an
encrypted message
and store it in the encrypted message
variable
so you'll see that we're going to use
the function that we defined
in this other module we're going to pass
in the public key that we got
from the file system that we created
earlier and
here is our super secret message that we
don't want
anyone to be able to decrypt over a
public channel
so once we do that we can
basically console log the encrypted
message as
a string and you'll see when i save
and run this file that in the
terminal you'll see some gibberish that
we cannot decrypt
so node main.js
and of course we see a bunch of
gibberish
this means absolutely nothing to us and
there's no chance that we figure out
what this super secret message was based
on this data
so in other words this right here is
what you're going to transport
over any sort of insecure transport
layer
so to decrypt this we can do that
with our private key so let's take a
moment to see how that works
we'll clear the terminal and create
another file
called decrypt dot
js and when we open that
up we can paste in a similar function to
the encrypt
file so we're going to require the node
crypto library define a single function
where we decrypt with the private key
and then
all this will take is our encrypted
message
and the private key and then it will use
the built-in
node crypto library private decrypt
function
so we're going to export this function
so that we can import it in another
module
save it and then we're going to use the
main module to actually decrypt this
okay so you're going to have to use your
imagination a little bit because
we're both encrypting and decrypting in
the same file
but hopefully this will make a little
bit of sense so
at the top part of the file we have
encrypted our super secret message right
here
at the bottom part we are going to
import our private key
and then we're going to use the decrypt
function and we're passing that
encrypted message
into the decrypt function and finally
we'll take that decrypted message
and convert it to a string and print it
to the console
so what we should expect with this file
now is that in the console we're going
to get that gibberish message that is
encrypted
and then finally we will have the
decrypted message which
should say super secret message so let's
run that real quick
we'll say oop come down to the terminal
we'll say node main.js
and we have a problem so let's see what
the problem is
decrypt is not defined because i did not
import it so let me import that real
quick
now that we've imported it we can use
the function
let's try one more time so we got the
gibberish
up top and then we finally got the
decrypted message at
the bottom so that is just a basic way
that you can understand
how we use private and public key pairs
to
protect data over an insecure transport
layer
in order to see how digital signatures
work
we're going to have to add a few things
to our encrypt and decrypt
modules because remember we are going to
encrypt
and decrypt with different keys based on
which use case we want to
use so let me do in the encrypt
encrypt function or module i'm going to
add another function
called encrypt with private key so we
can
encrypt with the public key in case of
data protection
or we can encrypt with private key in
case of a digital signature
so let's go ahead and export that from
this module real quick
so encrypt with private key
so now we have a module called encrypt
which we can do both
encryption with the private or the
public key likewise we need to do this
in the decrypt module
so let me just highlight this whole part
paste it in
we've got an extra import here and we've
got our function
decrypt with public key so now that we
have those components we can see how
a digital signature actually works but
mind you
a digital signature is a little bit
different
than protecting data we're going to have
to go through
just a little bit extra work to do this
because this is a little bit more
complicated i'm actually going to
make separate files for the steps of the
process
so with the digital signature we have
some sort of data
that we want to put our signature on so
just think of it like a legal document
you have the document itself with the
data and you want to sign it
and you want to make sure that the
receiver of that data
is assured that both the data that was
on the document
has not been tampered with we don't want
someone intercepting it and changing
some of the legal proceedings on that
paper
and we also want to make sure that the
person
we think signed it actually did sign it
so that's step one we need to sign the
message
step two is actually verifying it as i
just described
so for step one let me go ahead and
close all of these files
you know what's you know what is in them
so we will create
a sign message dot js
file and
in this file let's go ahead and import
some
different modules so let me walk you
through what's actually happening here
starting from the top we have the node
crypto library
pretty familiar we also have the
file system and then we have the
encrypts and decrypt modules that we
created ourselves
now the last thing is this hash function
and this is a sha 256 hash we talked
about this a little bit earlier
and it is a trapdoor function that takes
a
pretty much infinitely large or small
piece of data
and you put that data through the hash
function
and the output of that hash function
is going to be every single time you do
it it's going to be the same
exact value and that value is going to
be small enough that we can kind of
transport
to different places it's always going to
be 64 characters long
which each character is four bits so you
have 260
or 256 bit value that is always
going to come out of that function no
matter how big or small the data you put
into it finally at the bottom
you'll see that i have a piece of data
this is going to be the data that we're
going to
sign now you'll see that i've got my
first and last name
and then in the social security number
field
we're never going to put that because
remember
this second use case of signing some
sort of data
does not protect the data itself if
someone intercepted this data on an
insecure channel
they would be able to read everything
that
is contained in it so we never want to
put
any sort of confidential information
in data that we are digitally signing
all right so the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
take
this data right here since it's pretty
large and we need to compress it down
into that sha-256 hash so
to do that deleted it to do that
i'm going to paste in some code that i
wrote earlier
and what this code is going to do is
first
store the json string value
of this data right here
and it's going to store that in a
variable and what we're going to do
is we're going to use that node crypto
library hash function
and we're going to hash the data that i
just put in string form
then we're going to convert that into
hexadecimal format
and this is important because the
format that we're passing values between
function in is actually really important
when we're using
the crypto library we are now ready to
actually sign this data so let's paste
in
some more code first we're going to get
access to the private key that we
created earlier
in second we are going to store the
signed message
in a variable we're going to use the
encrypt with
private key function that we created
using the node built in crypto library
we're going to pass in the the sender
private key
so in this case i am the sender of this
data
and i own a private key that i'm going
to sign
this message with so i will sign
the data with my private key and
this data is going to be in the form of
the hash
data so we're not just going to sign
this big data
object we're going to sign the hashed
version
of that data now the last thing that we
have to do
is kind of that extra step that i was
talking about
so if you just sent this signed message
to someone they're not going to be able
to do anything with it
not only do we have to verify that
nobody has tampered with
our legal documents so to speak we also
need to verify
that the person that says they signed it
actually did sign it
to do that we need to provide the
receiver of this data
with a few additional pieces of
information
so those pieces of information is number
one
which hash function we used to hash the
data
number two we have to actually give them
the
original data so that they can
take the hash function take the hash of
it and then
they can eventually take the signature
that we provide them with
and match it up with that hash data
to make sure that the that i actually
signed the data in the first place
so let's go ahead and see what that
looks like we'll go ahead
and create a final piece of data so
we'll say
package of data
to send to be very explicit
and we'll paste in this data object
so we've got an algorithm so this tells
the receiver of data i want you to use
the sha 256
algorithm and what i want you to put in
that algorithm
is the original data that we created
so you'll see that the original data is
my data
which is the original object of data
that we will use
and then of course we have the signed
and encrypted data which we
assign to the signed message right here
so
with this information a receiver of this
data
can verify using my public key
that not only was the data not tampered
with but i also
signed it last let's go ahead and export
this package of data
so module dot exports dot
data or let's just call it the same
thing that we called it here
package of data to send equals
package of data to send so we can access
this from
another file to do this we're going to
create another file
called verify identity.js
we'll open up that file and we'll
put our imports in there so we need the
crypto library
we need that decrypt module that we had
created on our own
and then we need to import the data
that we just exported from that other
module
so this is everything that we need to
verify
this message now we also need to
bring in the public key of the sender
so this will be made publicly available
and we'll say that you know i sent this
data in the first place but my friend
jim whatever is going to be verifying it
so jim will need my public key
to do this which again public key
is public and anyone can see it you can
feel confident that they're never going
to be able to figure out what the
private key was
and one thing you'll notice that i
required this in but i
need to grab the variable that we
exported
so require this module
and the variable so our received data is
equal to
this object right here in the sign
message
file next we need to actually
take our own hash of the data that we
were provided
so to do that we know that we're using
the sha-256 hash
and so we can use that hash function to
hash the original data
i'll paste this in here and you'll see
that our hash function
is going to be the built-in node hash
function
and it's going to be the algorithm that
was in that
data package so i know this is a little
confusing
but this line right here in the verify
identity file
is the same as this import right up here
so where we said create hash sha 256
we're also creating a hash and we're
just using that
algorithm that we've received in the
data package
like i said we also need the public key
of the
sender so we'll go ahead and get that in
the public key variable
the next step to doing this is we have
to take
that data that was signed and decrypt it
so let's think about what this is
actually doing
i'm going to paste in the code and we're
going to use our decrypt module
we're going to pass in the public key
right here this is the public key
of the sender and then we're going to
take the
the data that we received and we're
going to pass in the signed
and encrypted data so if we come over
back to the sign message let's figure
out what this was
so our signed and encrypted data was our
signed
message which basically if we
decrypt that message what it's going to
give us
is the hash value that we derived from
this
original data so what we're going to get
in this variable right here
the decrypted message is simply
a hash value so in order to verify that
we can then take our own hash of the
data that was provided
in this object right here so this is the
original data
and if we take a hash of that and
compare it to
the decrypted message here they should
match
and if they do match we can know that
not only was the data not tampered with
but it was also
signed by the person who said that they
signed it
one extra step we've got to do is we've
got to turn that decrypted message
into a string value to pass it into our
function
that's just a formatting thing finally
we say
we want to look at the hash of the
original
so we're going to actually take the hash
of the data that was passed to us in
that data package
and then we're going to turn that into
a hex value to verify it we'll just do a
basic
if then statement so we'll say if the
hash of original hex so basically
our own so this is the receiver of data
jim is doing this he's taking
a hash using the designated hash formula
and just turning it into a hexadecimal
value so that we
are comparing apples to apples and then
we're taking the decrypted message hex
which is basically what came with that
is what we decrypted in comparing them
so
if it is the same then we're going to
say success the data has not been
tampered with and the sender is valid
so let's see if this works let's go down
to our console and run
node verify identity
and you'll see that it says success data
hasn't been tampered with we have the
right sender
so hopefully that makes sense that is
the second
use case of public key or asymmetric
cryptography
and is called a digital signature it's a
very common way to
verify data and identities and you'll
see if you are following the passport.js
series that this video is kind of
associated with
you'll see exactly how that works when
we actually are
authenticating users now just as a
consolation
for this video what we just did
over the last few minutes when we were
signing
and verifying a message is the same
exact process that is used with json web
tokens
so you might say wait a second there
might be
a better way to transport this package
of data over the internet
and you are right there is indeed a
better way to do this
if we were to send this package of data
it's going to actually
be a pretty large piece of data and it's
going to slow
all of our web searches down especially
if we're using it for some sort of
authentication
so naturally the easier way to do this
is to represent this piece of data in a
much
smaller form just like we took the
original data and we took a hash of it
to make it smaller
and more transportable we can also do
that with the data package
that is sent to the receiver of data and
is used to verify the original data
let's jump into the browser real quick
and what i have pulled up
is jwt dot io
which has a really simple jwt
visualizer per se now don't focus on
what is going on here because i have a
separate video
on that but just recognize
the structure of what's going on so on
the left
this is our entire jwt token
and you can see that it is pretty short
and it would be very easy to transport
over the internet
in a quick and efficient manner but if
we decode this jwt
it has the same critical information
that we
saw when we were signing and verifying
an identity
in our code earlier so first we have
the algorithm which is represented by
this reg string
and so this will tell us exactly what
sha or sha 256 hash algorithm that we
have to use to decrypt the data
then we also have a payload which is
represented by this purple string
and you can see i guess i deleted
something here but you can see that it
has
all of the information that we would
need to include
in that payload of data so this you
could consider
that legal document that we are signing
and then finally at the bottom you have
the actual
signature and the signature is going to
include um you'll see the public and
private key here
but this is actually just going to be
the signature that we wrote in the code
earlier and we can
verify it with a public key all right
now that you have a basic understanding
of public key cryptography
we can move on to understanding what is
a json web token
now i could of course go through a basic
example and just show you the pieces and
all that stuff
but i want to take it even further as i
promised this
is you know hopefully one of the most
detailed user authentication
courses that you've ever taken and in
that light
i want to actually derive and sign our
own
implementation of a json web token using
some of the
internal node.js libraries the questions
that i'm going to answer in this video
is first what is a json web token
we will then go into answering the
question of
how do we derive a json web token like
what are the
pieces of it and how would we actually
create one
using code and then finally i'll give
you a little bit of context
as to how it applies to user
authentication
among other use cases we'll start the
video off by
looking at the jwt or json web token
spec
on the internet engineering task force
it is going let me switch to google
chrome real quick
you'll see that they have a write up on
jwt's
and the specification for using them
we'll come back to this in a minute to
look at a few things
but um this is a very well established
type of token per se i guess you could
call it a token
that we use to transport some sort of
data
on the web now something a little bit
more friendly that we can look at
is a website called jwt dot io
and right here i am looking at the
example
jwt and we're going to be able to
visualize
what is going on a lot easier once we
kind of understand what the jwt
is we'll actually go into writing some
code
to kind of replicate this example right
here
so to understand jwt it's pretty simple
there are three parts you have the
header
the payload and the signature now the
header and the payload
pretty easy to understand the signature
not so much because there's actually
multiple types of signatures that you
can do
and therefore it adds a little bit of
complexity
on top of that a signature is a digital
signature and it has to do with public
key cryptography
or just symmetric cryptography depending
on which algorithm you're using
so it requires a little bit of
background knowledge which is why i
recommended
watching that video that i had created
on public key cryptography before this
one
now you'll see in the algorithm field up
top
we can kind of scroll through all the
different choices that we have
for writing a digital signature on a jwt
but in our case since i had you watch
the public key cryptography video
we're going to do the rs 256 algorithm
which is basically as you'll learn more
when we get into the code
is telling us two things so number one
we're going to use rsa private and
public keys
that standard and then number two we're
going to use the sha
256 hashing function to actually take a
hash
of the header and payload data
i know that's a mouthful we haven't
learned anything yet so
just hold on to that knowledge in the
back of your head we'll come back to it
and understand it
in a lot greater detail in a few minutes
let's start out by getting a basic
understanding of what a json web token
is
so i mentioned that it was made of three
parts you have the header the payload
and the signature and these are
highlighted on the page here
in the different colors and they are
separated
by a single period so the first part in
red
is the header then you have the pink
part which is the payload
and finally this turquoise part is
the actual digital signature now
what you're looking at right here is
base64 url
encoding and i'm not going to get super
into it but just
a few fun facts about base64 url
encoding it's a encoding
spec that basically aims to standardize
character sets and it's derived from the
base64 encoding
which was originally created well before
you know my time of learning to code but
from what i understand the idea there
was previously before the utf-8
standard where we had you know
standardized character sets
there was debates over whether you know
there should be
four bits or five bits or seven bits or
eight bits within a single byte
of data and before that was standardized
as eight
bits per byte there was varying
use cases and different you know
protocols and applications would use
different number of bits in a byte
and so therefore you might have an
application
that actually cuts off the last two bits
of data so what base64 was
aiming to do was basically add this
thing called
padding into the data and so
it makes it so that there's no chance
that any of the data is going to get
lost in transport and then the base 64
url
encoding is just one extra step because
there were some characters within the
base64
encoding that are not exactly url
friendly or file name friendly so
converting base64 to base64 url just
makes it safe to transport
over the internet and we also know
that this format in general is not going
to
lose any data which is obviously very
important
when we're talking about user
authentication which is
a very common use case for jwts i know
that was a bit of a long-winded
explanation of an encoding um not so
interesting but
as we actually derive this jwt
with code you're going to see that we're
kind of constantly having to shift
between
the different encodings and it's going
to become a little bit more important
later
all right now that you know what you're
looking at here on the left
let's talk a little more conceptually
what we're seeing here
on the right side so on the right side
all we've done is we've taken these
base64 url
encoded characters
and we've decoded them into json
objects and in the header you'll see
that we just have a couple things
we have an algorithm and a type
and this is pretty self-explanatory but
when you're transporting
json web tokens over the web
it's not always the case that the
receiver of the json web token
is going to know you know anything about
the json web token to start with
so in the header the sender of the json
web token or the issuer
is going to identify which algorithm
they use to create the digital signature
and then of course we say that the type
of token
is a jwt because there's actually other
types of token
tokens that we can use here aside from
just json web tokens
so we have again chosen the rs
256 algorithm which says we're using
public key cryptography
for the digital signature along with the
sha-256
hashing function and what we're going to
do
is well actually before i get into this
let's cover what the payload is then
we'll get into that signature
so the payload is basically going to be
metadata about some entity
and in most cases it's going to be
about a user because jwts are
commonly used for user authentication
so in this payload you're not going to
see any sort of credentials
if you see credentials in a jwt
payload then you know that the developer
has done something wrong
because you should never ever put
credentials or sensitive
information in the payload it's publicly
available
anyone could decode this jwt
just using a simple base64 url
decoding algorithm so what this data
gives us is just general information
about the user so you'll see the sub
or subject is going to tell us who the
user is
in many cases you'll see some sort of
database
id put in here so that when
an application decodes the jwt
they see okay here's the sub it is
this id let me look up this id in my
user table and retreat retrieve the full
user
object so that's what the sub is
um name obviously just the name admin
just another metadata
property and then iat is
issued at so it gives you the time stamp
of when the jwt
was issued now we also have additional
um what they call claims that's kind of
the proper term for these
pieces of data we have additional um
claims that we can define and if you go
over to the
specification for jwts
you have all this information but down
here at the bottom
or somewhere in the middle we have the
registered claim names
so these are registered it says the
following claim names are registered in
the iana
json web token claims registry
established by section 10.1
so in other words these are kind of the
official
claims that you'll be using and if you
wanted to issue jwbts that would be
interpreted by
various applications you would want to
use these standard claims
so that everyone knows exactly what they
mean
so let's just go through the most common
ones and then
there's a few others at the bottom you
can look through on your own
so first is the issuer claim this is
going to
identify the issuer of the jwt
now in our case we probably don't need
this because
we are both issuing and verifying a jwt
within the same application
but in many cases for more complex
architectures
you'll see a certificate authority
who is actually being it's the
certificate authority acts as
the third party authority that is
trusted
to issue jwt tokens and that is
literally
all they do so we have we basically can
establish
a centralized authority that everyone
trusts
and that centralized authority will sign
the jwts with their private key
and because they sign it with their
private key
they'll say okay here's our public key
and anyone in the world can say okay i
trust that institution
and i'm going to verify this jwt with
their public key
if it matches i know that this jwt
was issued by a trusted authority so
that's kind of where you'll see the
issuer claim
the subject claim we already covered the
audience claim
is going to generally be the
resource that will accept this jwt
so in other words um if the jwt is only
intended to be used with
a specific application um it would
probably list some sort of url or base
url
that will identify which server the jwt
is valid for
so in other words if google issued a jwt
token they might put in the audience
claim www.google.com
and if the jwt is attempted
if if you attempt to use the jwt in a
different
context other than google.com it's going
to be rejected
then finally we have the expiration
claim which basically tells you
when or what point in time this jwt
token
is no longer valid there are additional
claims that you can put in here we saw
the iat
issued at claim but you can also
and this is important you can also make
up your own claims
this by no means has to be standardized
you can put whatever metadata that you
want
in the payload and last but not least we
have the
signature at the bottom we've already
kind of touched on it
i talked a lot about how this actually
works from
a cryptography perspective in that video
that i asked you to watch before this
one
again link is in the description for
that
but anyways i think it would be helpful
to
go through kind of a conversation
between the server
and the client to understand how this
jwt is working
in real life so i've put together a
basic
little representation of this and
what we have here is what i kind of
perceive
as the conversation that the server and
the client would have
if they could talk to each other in
human terms of course
so the server just think of this as
any application we're kind of removing
the idea of certificate authorities from
this
basic equation we're just going to
assume that the server
will just say it's an expressjs
application
is both issuing and verifying the jwt
tokens
so we don't have that third party
certificate authority in this equation
so what's going to happen is our client
or just
basically our user someone sitting
behind a computer who is
visiting our application on the web is
going to go to the login page
and say hey server i want to log in to
your application
here's my username and my password
then the server gets that information in
the form of a post request
and it's going to say okay let me check
on that i want to go through my
verification algorithm and look you up
in my database to make sure that you
exist
and you entered valid credentials
we'll assume that the user did so the
server says
okay your credentials look great i'm
going to
sign a jwt token or
jwt with my private key
that only i know about so the server
is the only entity that has any
knowledge of that private key
they're going to sign it and send back
the jwt
in the response body so then the client
or the user
basically this this doesn't actually
have any user interaction it's invisible
to the actual person behind the computer
but the browser
or the frontend application is going to
receive the
the response and say hey thanks for the
jwt
i'll keep this stored in my browser's
local storage
until maybe it expires
so then the client is going to
once they're logged in they're going to
want to do something so
maybe this client wants to go edit their
profile
so they'll type in the url of the
profile
just say some site.com this is just an
arbitrary value
and then they're going to need to attach
that jwt token
or i keep saying jwt token
but it's json web token to the
http header that's called the
authorization header
and so in the authorization header is
where that's going to be stored the
server is going to receive that jwt
in the request body and
then we're going to say okay i just
talked to you
we're familiar but i still need to
verify that jwt
because i don't know if in the time that
you
chose to visit the profile did someone
tamper with it
so we're going to take the jwt and now
the server says okay
i signed it with my private key but now
i'm going to take my public key
that everyone knows about but i don't
care because
it doesn't actually matter i'm going to
take that public key
and verify the signature on that jwt
and the server says okay that signature
is indeed valid i know that
you know you are actually you and the
claims made
on the body of this jwt are valid
let me go ahead and look you up in the
database load your user profile
and give you the information required to
actually edit that user profile
so that is the basics of how a jwt
works i'm going to in a few minutes go
through the
code for deriving a jwt but i will also
mention
again this video was intended to be kind
of part of
my node.js passport.js
video series which the playlist is
listed in the description below
if you wanted to know more about what we
just talked about
how this actually works in practice
written
in code say for an angular application
go ahead and follow that series through
the end
use the passport jwt authentication
strategy
and you'll see exactly how this works in
practice
but for now we're going to jump into the
code editor
and actually see this process written
out
how we issue a jwt and then how we
verify
that jwt just using the built-in
nodejs crypto library to start off with
we're going to go through this part
where we issue
a jwt to keep it as simple as possible
i'm going to take the example off of
jwt.io
so if you visit this you should see the
same thing
and i'm going to actually be showing you
how
we get to this jwt how we actually issue
this one
and then how we verify it using the
public and private key
so you should be able to verify how this
works by just coming to this site
and you can actually follow along with
the node.js crypto library
so i'm going to go ahead and just copy
this entire token
again this is in base64 url format
or encoding so i'm going to copy that
and then we're going to come into the
code editor and paste
it in here so i first need to create a
file
so let's just say issue
jwt.js
and you can see that on the left here
i've already pasted in the private and
public key
those came from that jwt.io website
alright so i've copied in the key right
here let me just put this
as a string
and store it in some sort of variable
so we'll say const jwt equals
that so this is the exact jwt that we
saw from that
example website now in order to
properly do this we need one npm library
and it's called base64 url so i've
already installed it but you'll come
down here
to your terminal and install base64
url to follow along with this
so i'm going to go ahead and require
that in real quick
so we'll say base 64 url
and now we can take this jwt right here
and convert it into something that we
can actually
work with we now need to split up this
jwt
into its parts which if you remember is
designated or delimited by this period
so we can do that using some simple
javascript
so we'll say jwt parts equals
jwt dot split and we'll specify
that period so now if we were to
console.log the jwt parts
we should have an array of those three
parts
so let me go ahead and try that real
quick
and you can see that we have an array
and the array contains the three
different pieces of that jwt token
again these are still in base64 url
encoding
let's go ahead and split these into
variables
so i've just written this code already
we basically say
header in base64 url url format
is going to be the first one so in our
array right here
we're just grabbing that piece and then
so on and so forth with the remaining
two
now what we have to do is we have to
actually take this base64 url format
and convert it to something else
now that we have this in pieces we can
decode this
with the base64 url decoder
the npm module we included up here
and we can see the actual json objects
that these represent
so let me put those in variables real
quick so we have the decoded header
payload and signature
and we're just using that base64 library
and using the decode method and we're
passing in
the base64 url pieces
and then finally we can console.log
those to the terminal and you can see
what they look like
decoded so let's go ahead and
console.log those
we're just taking these three variables
here and logging them
save the file let's give us some space
in the terminal here
and let's run this again
so you're going to see the first part is
the same thing that we saw on google
or on the in the browser at jwt.io
and the second part also so these match
perfectly
as we would expect and then we have a
bunch of gibberish at the bottom
and the reason being is because we
haven't
actually um decrypted
the signature yet so once we decrypt the
signature
then it will be in a format that we can
understand
a little bit better now that you've seen
this decoded
i'm going to actually comment all of
this out for a second
because we don't need this we're going
to actually derive
this jwt from scratch so commenting that
out for a second we'll just space it
down to the bottom
and what we're going to do is actually
create this from scratch
by first creating the javascript objects
that we want to
put in the header and the payload so you
can see that these are the exact same
header and payload objects that we
printed
in json format below now obviously these
are in
javascript format so we will need to
convert them
into json format by saying using the
json.stringify method
so let's do that right now i pasted in
the json.stringify method
and stored these two objects as json
strings
in these two variables the next thing
that we have to do
because right now these are just in json
format
we need to actually convert that json
format into the base64 url
so to do that we'll use this base64 url
library and we'll just put it through
the basic function
and convert it so here we go copy this
in i'm just copying code that i wrote
before to speed things up
but anyways we have new variables
hopefully these are labeled
appropriately for you but we
have a base64 url header and payload
all we've done and we actually need to
change this a little bit so we're going
to just use our import here
base64 url and the basic function that
comes with that library
is just a function to convert any sort
of
object into the base64 url format
so these two variables store the correct
format for our header and our payload
now we have to actually sign
and issue the jwt but first let's go
ahead and check this
we're just going to console log these
two values
to make sure that we have actually
converted
these original javascript objects
correctly
so let's go ahead and clear the terminal
give us some space and run this again
and you'll see these two values which we
can actually
check from the commented out code so
here's our original jwt that we just
took from the website and posted right
in there
and you'll see that this first value
matches the first value
of there and then the second one if you
wanted to go out there and confirm that
it also matches so we've got what we
need
again the last thing we have to do is
actually take some sort of hash
of these two pieces of data and then
sign that hash
and put that in the signature in order
to sign this we need to import a few
more libraries
so at the top i've imported the built-in
node.js crypto library
and then from the crypto library we can
also
implement the algorithm that we're using
for this jwt
so this is going to allow us to sign the
jwt
using this specific algorithm and then
we need the file system
from the node.js framework so that we
can access the private and public key
that we have saved in this current
directory
now that we have our imports let's come
down here get rid of these console logs
and we're going to create the signature
so the first step is to use this
signature function
and we want to write some sort of data
into it so
right here we're just passing in the
header and the payload separated by this
period
and this is going to be the data that is
actually
hashed using the sha 256 hashing
function
this is all kind of done within this
node crypto library
but we're going to hash this data and
then we're going to sign the hash
so we've loaded the data in here the
last thing that we have to do
is load our private key which we're
going to be signing it with
and then use the signature function sign
method
to actually sign the jwt here is the
code to do that
copy it in first we need to load our
private key
that's literally just loading this
private key pen
file and i actually need to change the
name for this
to work correctly so private key dot
pem and it's important to put this in
utf-8
encoding and then we are going to
convert
this is kind of an important part
we are going to sign this data
which is going to give us a base64
encoded signature so then to actually
derive the jwt
we're going to have to convert base64
to base64 url we can do that with this
imported library right up here
so i'll show you the code for that
here's the code that we use to do that
so we just basically take the signature
that we got from the node crypto library
and we convert it from base 64 to
base64 url so now the signature should
be
in the same exact format that we were
expecting
earlier let's go ahead and
verify that real quick so signature
base64 url we'll print that out
really quickly
and you're going to see this value right
here
let's go ahead and just verify it real
quick so here again is our jwt
we need to come all the way out to the
last piece of it
and here we go there's the last piece
and you can see that the first couple
letters are matching up
and if you were to go through all of it
it's going to match
to the character so right there
we from scratch created a jwt token
using the node.js crypto library
now there is an easier way to do this
and i will show you that in a few
minutes
but first we need to verify this jwt
that we just
issued since we already have a lot of
the
basics set up we're just going to
uncomment some of this code to verify
the signature
so let me just make a comment for this
first part
probably should have just named this
file jwt
because we're doing both the issuance
and the verification
in the same file so here is the issuance
part
right here and then
end of issuance
and then here is the verification
and we will go ahead and implement this
now
so when we verify at jwt
we are basically receiving the jwt in
the base64 url format
in this case we just are going to use
this one right here the one that we just
created
because we know that um it's exactly the
same as that example online
so to get the jwt parts we're going to
uncomment that
we will uncomment this part we don't
need
any of these things right here
and i think we're set so now we can
actually verify this jwt to do this
we'll actually have to just create one
more line in the imports
and this is going to be the verify
function
from using the same exact algorithm
so we've got the issue or the create jwt
function and then the create verify or
the verification function
as the verifier of this jwt
we have received the entire jwt
right here we've split it into parts and
now we have to actually do something
with those parts
so the first thing we'll do is we'll
take the header
and the payload and just like the
signer of the or the issuer of the jwt
did we're going to take the header and
the payload
and append them together separated or
delimited by the period
and since the the node.js crypto library
only accepts base64
encoding we need to take the base64
url signature and convert it using the
base64 url
npm module to base64.
so now that we have that we can finally
i guess decrypt the signature so we're
going to take our
public key that corresponds to the
issuer
issuer's private key and we're going to
decrypt
the signature so the first thing we need
to do
is actually get the private or the
public key in here
so i'm going to just copy this line and
use that we'll say
public key and we just need
public key dot pem so now that we've
imported our public key that we're
verifying with we are finally ready to
verify this jwt
so let's copy this in the signature is
valid variable
is basically going to run the node.js
crypto library
verify function that we imported
right here so verify function
dot verify we're going to pass in the
public key
that we imported from the file system
we're going to
pass in the jwt signature base64
format and then the most important part
this will really trip you up it took me
honestly
hours to actually get this to work
because i
had not included the base64
format in the verify function so that's
really important
and once you've done that we should
console.log the signature is valid
and i think it returns a boolean whether
it's valid or not
so let's go ahead and try that really
quickly
node issue well it's not really issue
jwt but bear with me
we get first the signature that we were
console logging
right up here and then the signature is
valid variable
returns true so we have successfully
verified this jwt and
essentially we've gone through the whole
process so we
created the jwt from scratch and then we
verified it from scratch
now if you wanted you could use all the
code that we just
used in this example for your web
applications to
sign and verify jwt tokens
but like i said earlier there is an
easier way to do this
and that easier way is using the json
web token
npm library and what this
library is is basically an abstraction
of the node.js crypto library and it
gives you a little bit
you know more options because in this
example we were just using the rsa256
algorithm and we didn't even get into
okay what if we use a different jwt
algorithm
so the json web token library is going
to give you a lot of flexibility
and it also kind of abstracts away all
of the things
all of these you know when we have to
convert from base64 url to base64
you don't have to worry about doing that
in this library
so this would be the library that i
would recommend using
in any sort of web application where
you're issuing and verifying
jwts and in the next few minutes i will
show you
exactly how to use it to save us a
little bit of time
i've just copied in my implementation
of the json web token library um
if we wanted to accompl accomplish the
same exact things that we did with the
node
crypto library now obviously since this
is abstracted a little bit
you're not going to get to see the
little bits and pieces that are
happening
and you don't get to truly understand
what is happening with the jwt
but it does make your life a lot easier
when you're actually coding
so let me explain to you what's going on
here the first thing you'll notice
is i imported the json web token library
i already installed it with npm install
json web token so that is
what that import represents we use the
file system
the node.js file system to grab the
public key
and the private key that we were using
earlier
so again this is the public key and
private key from that example
on jwt.io and then
you'll notice this payload object is
very similar
we've seen it before because it's the
exact same payload object
but you might notice that you don't see
the
header and the reason being is that is
one of the things that this library
abstracts away all we have to do
is provide the algorithm and the library
creates the header on its own so you'll
see
in this next line we have a variable
called the signed
jwt which is a product
of the json web token library
sign method where all we have to do is
pass in the payload object
in javascript form so we don't have to
do any of that json.stringify stuff and
then
convert it to base64 url none of that we
can just pass in a
javascript object then of course we pass
in the private key that we want to
actually
sign it with as we know that's how
jwts work and then finally in the
options object
we just have to give it the algorithm
that we want to use
and based on this algorithm the json web
token library is going to
figure out what the header needs to be
so
it will then combined that header and
the payload
just as we did with the node crypto
library it's going to sign it
with i actually think they use the node
crypto library underneath the surface so
they
pretty much do exactly what we did
earlier to sign this
and then to verify it again just one
simple line of code or
a couple simple lines of code we just
used the json web token
verify method we passed it we pass in
the signed
jwt or this basically it's going to be
received
in the authorization http header
for a web application so we take that
jwt
pass it into the verify function we use
the public key that corresponds to the
signer's private key
in this case since we're doing the
signing or the issuance
and the verification it's just these two
this key pair and then again we have to
pass in the algorithms that
it will accept in this case rs256
and then we have a callback function
in the callback function if there's an
error we know that the
verification has gone wrong and
either we have the wrong public key to
verify this jwt with or the jwt
was tampered with and we don't want to
use it so let's go ahead
and just verify that this works really
quick so you can see it in action
i will console.log the signed jwt value
so let's just do that first really
quickly
and you'll see this value right here
which if you were to match with the
value
online it's going to be the same exact
thing so um you can do that on your own
time
but just trust me that is the same exact
jwt
and then here we can go into the
callback function
and let's say console dot
log air and we should expect
that we don't see any error whatsoever
because
we verified this successfully so we get
null as the air as expected and then
we can also console.log
the payload which is the second argument
that it returns
and you should get the same payload that
we had defined
right up here except this was when we
issued it
and then this is when we signed it so
you can see how this might work
in an actual application you might have
a post route that is going to
verify credentials and then it will sign
and return a jwt in the response
and then you might have another couple
routes that are like authenticated
routes
and you might have some sort of
middleware like passport.js
that is going to underneath the hood use
this jwt.verify method
and use the public key to verify
the jwts that are being passed through
the authorization headers
couple hours later and we're finally
ready for our second form of user
authentication
which is the passport jwt strategy i
think this next section is going to be
really rewarding for you
because we're about to take all of those
prerequisite
lessons that we went through whether
that be the
express middleware overview or
you know the basics of cryptography
we're going to combine those together
and put it into our user authentication
strategy
this one's going to be fun so let's jump
in the first part of this series we went
through the passport local strategy
and in doing so we talked a lot about
the inner workings of the passport
framework
and in this second part since it's a
little bit more advanced i'm going to be
skipping over those details
so if you find yourself lost
for example in the process of
generating and validating a username and
password in a database
or maybe the verify callback for the
passport middleware
i would suggest going back to the first
part of this series
and specifically just watching the
configuration video for the passport
local strategy
now before we start to code i want to go
through
the options that we have here when
implementing
a jwt authentication strategy
so we're working with the passport jwt
middleware
strategy but we don't necessarily
need to and this is going to be the most
confusing part for someone looking for a
solution on the internet because
there are all sorts of ways that you can
actually implement
a jwt strategy in your application
and because of that you'll have people
who understand
json web tokens pretty well and they'll
have their own custom strategy working
but they won't explain kind of how they
got to that strategy
and it leaves you the reader of the
tutorial
just thinking to yourself well what's
the actual correct way to do this
and in this video i've stuck with the
passport jwt middleware
not because it's a hundred percent
necessary but because i think it's kind
of grounded
and it gives us a framework to start
with
and then we can kind of customize on the
fringes
as we see fit if we were trying to
be very complex about this and
probably the reason you would do this if
is if you were
maybe trying to write your own
authentication framework
or you're building your own
authentication server or something that
you have to do that's extremely custom
the most complex thing that you could do
is you'd
use the node.js crypto library and
then pair that with your own express
middleware
that work together to authenticate your
users
now i have no interest in doing this
because there's a lot of code that you'd
have to write to do that
but given the fact that we actually went
through the process
of issuing and verifying jwts with the
node.js crypto library
you already have a pretty good head
start if you did choose to use this
now the somewhat complex method for
authenticating users via jwt would be
to use something like the json web token
npm library which is going to give you
a little bit more abstraction you have a
lot less things to think about when
you're actually issuing and verifying
the jwts
but you're still left with writing your
own
custom middleware for your express
application
so that leads us to the least complex
method which is what we are going to do
and that is to use the json web token
npm
library so it's going to be really
simple to
issue and verify the jwts and then we'll
use
the already built framework passport.js
and then plug in the passport jwt
strategy into that framework
so we have our middleware written for us
but you don't need this like i said
there's a lot of different ways that you
can do jwt
authentication the reason we're going to
go with the passport jwt
strategy is because it kind of just
takes
takes care of some of the tedious things
like
say air handling or extracting
the token from the authorization http
header
like all of those things you have to
write your own code for
which is also going to be airprone and
you've got to test it
so we would prefer to kind of offload
that to
a framework that's already been tested
and used by
a lot of different use cases
so that's kind of why we're starting
with the passport jwt strategy but
wanted to lay that out for you
the last thing that i want to go through
before we get into this
is the basic conceptual flow of how
jwt authentication is going to work
now this slide right here assumes that
you understand the issuance and
verification process of
a jwt which again was in that
prerequisite video
in this playlist but anyways what
happens
is a user is going to log into web app
so we'll assume that they're already
registered um they're already stored in
the database
our application is going to go through
the basic password verification process
i talked about that
in the session based authentication or
the passport
local video but basically all we're
doing is we're taking the
the username that the user is going to
log in with
we look up that user in the database
and then in the database we have a salt
and a hash
stored for that user then we're going to
use some of the
um node.js crypto library methods to
actually take the plain text password
that the user just passed to us
and compare it against the salt in the
hash that were stored for that user
record in the database
if the user has validated correctly
based on our logic
then we are going to use we'll say the
json web token
npm library to issue them a new jwt
token
now this jwt token has
information about that user as well as a
signature from the server itself
so one of those pieces of information is
probably going to be the database id
of the user so then the user
client which is usually a browser
is going to store that jwt
so back up just a second the server
issues the jwt and sends it in the
response body of the http request
then the user client receives that http
request
and stores the jwt that it received
there
in local storage or maybe even a cookie
it doesn't exactly matter where you
store it it just has to be
persistent storage in the browser then
on
every single http request that requires
some sort of authentication
so maybe you're trying to access a
protected api
the user is going to or the user client
is going to attach that jwt in
most commonly but not always the
authorization
http header the important thing is that
you put that jwt in the correct header
that the server is
expecting and the authorization header
is just
the most common that you'll probably see
then
the server looks for that jwt in the
authorization header
because you've coded it to do so and
it's going to use the json web token
library to verify the signature of the
jwt
if the signature is verified we know two
things
we know that the jwt has not been
tampered with none of the data in it has
been tampered with
we know that it also came from the
person that we expected it to come from
so if the signature is valid the server
then will decode
the jwt which is in base64
url encoding so all we're doing is just
taking that from base64
url to json format
then we will read the um the payload
which is going to have information about
the user so we're going to probably go
for the payload.subfield
that's the most common place to find
this information
and it's where we're going to implement
it in this video
and we're going to grab from that field
is going to be the database id for the
user
so then the server is going to take that
id look up the user in the database
and then now it has the full user object
it can do whatever it wants with that
user object
in our case it's going to attach it to
the um
express request object and then we can
use it within our routes
and then finally once all that has
happened
the user is going to have access to the
resource
that they requested and our flow
is complete that's the process if you
ever find yourself confused as to what
we're doing
with the code later in this video in the
next couple videos
i suggest that you kind of keep this you
know pause the video on this slide take
a screenshot of it
maybe even print it out so that you know
exactly the
the pseudo code steps that we are going
through
okay so the next thing that we'll do is
come back to our
code and what i have open is
a github repository that you can
download yourself
and how i've structured it is we have
two branches
on this repository let me see if i have
it open in the browser we can just visit
it there
there we go so here's the repository
that we
that we have i just finished it up a few
minutes ago
but basically we have two branches to
work with
so the first branch that we have is
going to be master
and this is what you're going to have is
the default
when you clone this and it's going to
give you
a basic starter skeleton for
implementing the jwt authentication
strategy
as i talked about in other videos my
goal here is not to teach you how to
write an
angular app it's not to teach you how to
write an express app
and it's not to teach you how to use a
database with express
the goal here is to solely focus on the
authentication piece
so what i've done in this template is
i've done
all the implementation for all of those
pieces that i don't want to cover
and i've left blank the specific pieces
that relate to the authentication
alright so when you when you clone this
and you
come back to whatever code editor that
you're using
you'll go ahead and npm install in the
base
of the folder and then you also
over here i'm in the angular folder so
right here you'll go in the angular
folder and also type
npm install once you've done that then
you'll go to the dot env file
and you're going to enter these three
variables
now you don't necessarily have to do
this but
i guess if you're using this as like
kind of a starter
you'll eventually need to implement a
production
database string but this is going to be
entirely sufficient right here
and then you're also going to have to
come over to
this script right here generate key pair
and we talked about this in the
prerequisite video
on public key cryptography and this is
the exact
file that i used in that video and all
it's going to do
is create an rsa
public in private key pair and then it's
going to save it to the current
directory
now our passport jwt strategy is going
to use
this public key pair public private key
pair
to issue and verify the jwts
so you're going to need to generate this
the one thing that i'll note about
running this file if you run into an
error um trying to run this then it's
probably because your node.js version is
not great enough
i think there is some method here um
i don't know which one exactly it might
have been the generate key pair sync
from the crypto library but it was only
implemented
in i think it was version um
maybe 10 or something you can go ahead
and find that we're in the master branch
right here but in the final
branch you'll see exactly how to start
the app
and it's it gives you the required
node.js version i think it's like 10.
let's go let's just verify this right
now
um so let's go skip over to the final
branch which has the
final implementation of everything and
it's going to tell you that you need
version
10 point x or greater to do this script
right here
all right so make sure that you have
that
[Music]
set up and then you're going to just say
node
generate key pair and press enter and
what this will do
i might as well just do this right now
so let's delete what i've got right
here already and then say node generate
key pair and you'll see in the left side
here
it's going to pop up in a second you
should see
the public and private key pair that i
just created
um let's refresh it there we go so we
have the private key and the public key
and you should be good there and then
the last thing
that you need to know about the setup i
think
hold on one second that was actually it
so that's all you need to do to set up
uh you also need to sorry you also need
to run
the mongodb database in the background
um so go ahead and do that before you
run the app
and then when we actually run this app
we're going to
um it's not going to work here because i
haven't implemented everything
but we're going to run node app.js in
the root
and then ng serve in the angular
application
and then we're just going to visit the
angular application
to run the app but that angular
implementation
is the last video in the series if
you're not interested in that
then that's totally fine it's totally
optional
but it's just a common thing to see jwt
authentication in a single page
application
they're pretty compatible so that's why
i decided to include that last
video that last optional video okay
so you should be set up completely with
the repository
you've cloned it you've done your setup
steps now let's take
a very quick look at the code
i'm going to perf purposely try to fly
through this
and i'll assume that you're going to go
through on your own and get
yourself familiar with what is here
already
but i definitely want to go through a
few things
here so we'll start with the express app
because that is kind of the required
piece
let's open up app.js and you'll see that
we already have kind of our skeleton app
set up so of course we have express
we're going to import the cores module
and the reason being
is because in the optional
final video where we go through how to
implement this with angular
we're going to need to make http request
from localhost 4200 to localhost 3000
so from the angular app to the express
app
so you're going to need this course
piece in here
um path just going to give us access to
the um
the path that we want to save things in
the file system node.js
and then we're requiring in passport
um the dot m configuration i talked
about this in a previous video
but basically gives us access to um
the environment variables stored in the
dot env
file and we access those with process
dot env dot variable
name so that's how you will do that
set up our basic express app we're going
to import the configuration for the
database
which is right here um just scroll
through here it's basically saying
if we're in production environment
connect to the production string
if not connect to the development string
which is just running on localhost and
once it's connected we should just get a
little message that says
it's connected pretty simple there
all right so then we require in our
database models
which is one model and it is the user
so let's open up that real quick same
exact user schema that we used in the
first part of this
with the passport local strategy and
we're just having a username
and then the hash and salt will
represent the password in the database
then we will require in the
passport configuration which is where
we're going to configure the passport
jwt
strategy now it's a little bit weird
syntax
but basically in the passport
configuration
we are exporting a function that takes
the passport object
so we're importing the
passport library in app.js
and then we're going to pass this
variable
right here into the configuration
function
which will then receive access to that
and then in the body of the function it
will actually do the configuration
on that object so that's kind of how
that's working
we'll come back to that quite a bit so
don't worry about it
then we will initialize passport this is
required for
any passport strategy you always have to
initialize it so that it runs every time
that you make a route request these are
pretty simple
just body parser middleware except
now express has their own implementation
so we don't
have to do the body parser
middleware that you're used to seeing
probably so something like app.use
bodyparser.json we don't have to do that
because express has their own
implementation now here's the cores we
talked about
this line right here is going to allow
you to
kind of combine the angular and
express apps since the angular thing is
optional i'm not going to
go through it too much but it's going to
basically if we come over to angular
and type ng build it's going to build
all of the assets all the static assets
for that
application into this public folder and
then
express is going to use that public
folder
as the um static directory so in other
words
express is going to use the angular
build
as the front end for the application
all right so that's what that's doing
we're requiring requiring
in our routes which should just be um
okay so here's a basic route
configuration if you wanted to extend it
easily you could just add more route
files and then
add you know another line here that
would say
something like users will say
i don't know something like courses
maybe you're building some sort of
course module
and then you would have something
similar to users right here where we
have
all of the user routes so that's kind of
how you would extend that
and then in the user routes we just have
a protected route
which is going to allow us to test
whether we did the jwt
authentication correctly then we have
our standard login and register post
routes
which is going to allow us to issue the
jwt
and kind of validate the jwt
and finally we have app.listen which
will listen
on localhost 3000.
so that is the basic express app that
we're working with
and again i would hope that you would go
through this and get yourself a little
bit
more familiar but if you built a lot of
express apps
in the past this probably looks like a
pretty familiar structure
now in the angular app i will go ahead
and save that
we're not going to go through what's
happening in the angular app
until you actually get to the video on
angular so it kind of if you're not
wanting to watch that we're not going to
go through it and waste your time
with that i think i've gone through
everything that we need to
to get started with the passport jwt
user authentication strategy and
like the passport local strategy that we
did earlier in this series
it's going to follow a pretty similar
structure
so just like we did in the passport
local or
pretty much any passport strategy we're
going to need something called a verify
callback so in other words when we're in
our routes
so say we're in our login route
and we pass in a passport.authena
method what that method is going to do
is call the verify callback that we have
defined
in the passport configuration so if we
open up config
js it's going to be defined
right here so whatever we define within
these brackets
is what is going to be called when we
use the passport.authenticate method
as with any new package let's go ahead
and look at some of the documentation
so the documentation for passport jwt
i have it pulled up right here you could
also
go to strategies on the home page and
click passport jwt
to find it so the
documentation like most strategies
is not necessarily uniform all these
strategies are coded by different
developers so it's all
based on how that developer is going to
put it in there so
you can see here it's a little bit
jumbled up but it gives us
most of what we need to know the first
thing that i'll draw your
attention to is going to be right here
and you'll see that just like the
passport local strategy
the passport middleware as like a
framework is going to expect the same
three responses
so if our callback returns some sort of
error
whether it be a database error or an
express application error
we pass in the done callback
with the air parameter as the first
parameter and then false
for the user object then if we
successfully authenticate the user we
say that there's no error
and here's the user object which will
eventually be attached to the
express request object and then finally
if there is no error within our
application
but there's also an invalid user
then we're going to say there's no error
but there's also no user
so these three responses to this
verify callback is how passport knows
what to do
all right so now we got that covered
let's look at some of the options that
we're going to
be dealing with when we're using the
passport jwt strategy
so as we know we're going to call
passport.use
and then we're going to pass in a new
some sort of strategy
in this case it's the jwt strategy and
then that strategy is usually going to
take
options first and then the verify
callback
so those options here are going to be
defined up here at the top and
i will note that most of these options
are related
to the json web token npm library
so if we open that up here's the json
web token library
this is actually what the passport jwt
strategy is using to verify our jwt
so all of the options that you see here
so there's some examples here's the jwt
dot verify method
this is exactly what the passport jwt
middleware is using and all this
strategy is doing
is passing in the token that it receives
it's going to pass in the secret or
public key
so there's multiple ways that you can
verify
we're going to be using the public key
since we're using asymmetric
cryptography and then we have the
options
object which is literally going to be
just passed straight through
to this method from the passport
middleware
so you see down here we have all the
options that we can put in here
algorithms complete issuer ignore
expiration
all of these you'll also see well not
all of them but you'll see most of them
listed here in the strategy
documentation
now the way that we actually include
these options
is a little bit tricky and i
actually could not based on this
documentation figure out
how to get all of these option passed to
the verify callback
so what i've done is just put together
every single
option that you could possibly ever need
and i've put it in a single options
object
and then we'll kind of reduce to the
only the stuff that we need
going back to our code
let me just paste in this like
all-encompassing
options object and i might as
i might even leave this in the final
implementation just comment it out
but here is the full options object
if you were to pass in this obviously
you need to replace
some of these things with valid values
but if you were to pass this
in it would be readable by the passport
jwt middleware
so you'll see at the bottom we have the
json web token options
and this is where it gets a little
confusing because
here are some of those json web token
options that we saw in that library's
documentation
but there are also options from json web
token
that are that are passed up here and if
you were to pass
these down in the json web token options
the passport jwt middleware as it's
implemented
would not actually read them correctly
so it's really important that you put
the options i have listed here exactly
how you see them
if you see them in the json web token
options they need to stay there
so that is the entire all-encompassing
option object but we don't actually need
that
i'll go ahead and put this in the final
branch
of this repository but i'm going to
delete it out for
right now and we're only going to work
on what we need
the very first thing we'll do as with
any
module is import it so
we need the passport jwt strategy
and we're going to extract the strategy
off that so that's going to be a class
and then this extract jwt class
which is basically a little subclass
that is going to give you
options as to how you extract the jwt
from the http header if you look at the
documentation online
you'll see that this is detailed at the
bottom
so in the section extracting the jwt
from the request
this just has to do with that process
where the server needs to know how
and where that jwt is stored
in the request usually it's going to be
in the authorization
http header but it isn't always there so
this gives you some options as to where
you can find this
so we're going to just be using from
authheader as bearer token this is
probably one of the more common ways to
do it
but you could also pass it into
like a post request body field
you could put it in a url query param
and if you were to do that you would use
these different methods
from this class you could also write
your own extractor function
so i know i mentioned earlier that you
could put
the jwt in a cookie and
this right here just gives kind of that
example this is how we would grab it
from a cookie
and so you can kind of have some freedom
to implement whatever you would like
so our options object is going to be
pretty simple
just going to replace this right here
and this is what we're working with so
this is the options object that we're
going to need to implement
the jwt strategy first is what we just
talked about
the extract jwt class comes with
different methods for
finding that jwt and parsing it
so we're going to use the from auth
header as bearer token
so in other words it's going to expect
that we have our jwt sitting like this
so here's our authorization header and
then we're going to say
bearer and then a single space and then
here
is where our token is going to sit so it
expects this exact syntax
and if you were to maybe take the space
out or just delete the bearer
portion completely it's not going to be
able to read it correctly
you'll see how that works a little bit
later the next thing
is the secret or key
property and you can either pass in a
symmetric
or key which would just be a secret that
you stored in an environment variable
but for us since we're using the rs256
algorithm to issue and verify jwts
we're going to pass in our public key
that we generated with that
script right here and we're reading that
from the file system
it says path to key id rsa pub
and the reason that we're passing in the
public rather than the private
is because what we're configuring right
here
is the verify piece of the jwt
so if you remember we have the issuance
and then the verification
with a digital signature we sign the
issuance with the
private key and then we verify the
identify
or we verify the identity with the
public key
so that's why we're passing in the
public key because passport is the
verification step
of this process then finally we're just
passing in the algorithms that it will
accept
and we should be done with it so that's
our options object
obviously we didn't include half of the
options that were
available to us but i just wanted you to
know that those were available in case
you were doing something
a little bit different than me like i
did with the passport local strategy i'm
going to
kind of deconstruct this configuration
so that you're not just looking at a big
blob of
you know callback functions and options
and all that stuff
so we're going to keep it as modular as
possible here
the first thing that we do we have our
options object already configured
but we need to use the well jwt strategy
right here
so we're going to say const strategy
equals new jwt strategy
all right so that is going to take two
arguments one being the options object
that we defined
right here and two being
a callback function which is going to
it's already telling us what it expects
so it's going to
take a payload and a done
callback all right so that is the basic
implementation right here and then
we're going to actually configure it by
saying
passport.use
strategy
so again this passport object is being
provided from app.js then we're taking
that object
we're saying use so similar to a
middleware
and then we're passing in the strategy
which has the options configuration
in the callback function or the verify
callback
that we are about to implement within
the callback
as i mentioned with the passport local
strategy
the great thing about passport and also
the confusing part
is you don't have a specific way that
you're required to verify
in authentication and in our case
we can use whatever database we want we
can use whatever
you know code logic we want to do now
since we're using mongodb
we'll just use the find one method
on the user model so we've imported this
from our database configuration
so we'll just say user dot find one
and then we're going to pass in the id
and
where are we going to get this id from
well if you remember
from previously in this i think is in
the
first video we talked about how the jwt
payload so the second part of a jwt
is going to have a subfield well in our
case it has a subfield and in many cases
it has a subfield
that will include some information or
unique
identifier about the user in our case
when we implement
the register and login functions or the
routes we're going to issue a jwt
and we're going to place the mongodb
database id in the subfield
so here's our payload this is in
javascript object form so we can
literally just say
payload dot sub
and that's going to pass in the id that
we need to look up
our user in the database
we will then use promise syntax to grab
the user
and then we will catch any errors
that happen and if you remember we need
to pass
in the error to the done callback if
we um and no user
if there's an error within this
operation
so the last thing we need to do is
something in this
area where we have access to the user
that we just looked up
now if you were watching the passport
local strategy
you'll probably remember that in this
area we were doing all sorts of stuff we
were verifying
um you know using a crypto function we
were verifying the username and password
well in this jwt strategy it is much
much simpler
we are just we've already validated
this jwt so this strategy has
already gone through the process of
using the json web token library to
verify the jwt that it's received
so at this point when we're sitting
right here
we already know that our jwt is valid so
all we have to do is check if we found a
user in the database
and if we did we need to return it to
passport so that it can
attach that to the request object so
we'll just say if there's a user
we will return done
and there's no error but there is a user
otherwise we're going to return done
and we're going to say no air
and no user excuse me this is not null
this is
going to expect false so passport
expects to see
either a user object or false so
that is the implementation that we need
to do for this verify callback
it seems like nothing really is
happening
but behind the scenes the passport
jwt strategy is taking these options
it's grabbing that jwt from the
authorization header
it's validating that jwt with the json
web token library
then once it's validated it it passes
the payload
object right here then we grab the
id of the user from the payload sub
object
look it up in the database return it to
passport and then passport attaches it
to the request.user
object within the express framework so
that is all that we needed to do to
implement
passport jwt now i would try this out in
the browser and you know
see if it's working so far but the
problem is we haven't issued any jwts
so we could go generate a jwt
or grab an example from online and see
if it would work with this
but it never will because we have
generated
exactly zero jwts
using the private key that we generated
in this repository
so in other words when passport jwt
strategy tries to verify
the jw jwt we've included in the
authorization header
it's going to reject absolutely
everything
because there is no jwt in existence
right now
that corresponds to this private key so
when we
verify it with the public key it's just
going to reject it
so what we need to do is write some
logic in our login route
so that every time a user logs in we're
going to
issue them a new jwt that is signed with
the private key
that we are using from this server then
the passport jwt middleware will use the
public key that resides on this server
and will successfully verify these new
newly issued jwts
so to do this we need to come to the
routes so we're in the routes
users.js file and the first thing that
we'll
need to do is the register function
so if a user is going to come to our
application they obviously need to first
register
and basically what's going to happen in
both of these routes
is we're going to issue a jwt
regardless so the way that this flow is
going to work is
if a user comes to our application and
has never been there before and
registers they're just going to
provide their username and password then
we're going to store that
new user in the database and issue them
a new jwt
and then we're just going to consider
them logged in
for as long as that jwt is valid
and then the login is also going to
issue
a new jwt but it's just going to look up
the existing user in the database
and validate the user the username and
password that that user
put in there when they registered if you
watch the passport local strategy
videos you're going to be very familiar
with what i'm about to paste in
so what we're doing here in the register
function
is we are taking the plain text password
that the user has provided us with
and we're creating a salt in a hash
based on that plain text password we're
just using
some crypto utils so if we go in lib
you'll notice that these these two
functions valid password
and gen password are going to be the
same exact
um generation and validation functions
that we used with the passport local
strategy
and so you might ask yourself for a
second
well wait a second isn't this jwt isn't
this a jwt
strategy like why are we working with
like username and passwords and all that
kind of stuff
well you have to remember that the jwt
is simply a result of
a successful user authentication with a
username and password
so whether you're using the passport
local or passport jwt
authentication you're always going to
need to
know how to store a password in the
database and then verify it out of the
database
i'm not going to go through that if you
wanted to
really understand how this works
i do have a slide on that let me just
pull it up really quickly
so here is the basic password validation
process since i talked about it in
the passport local strategy a lot
just go watch that video if this doesn't
make sense otherwise just read through
this
really quickly all right so that's
basically what's happening
with the password generation and
verification
and in the register function we're doing
part one of that
so we're going to create the salt in the
hash and store those
in the user record in the database then
we'll save the user in the database
and just return a success message as
well as the user object
now i also mentioned that we're going to
be issuing
a jwt here which we will do in one
second
but i want to first look at the function
that is creating that jwt
so we go to the bottom of the utils
and you see that we have exported this
issue jwt function
which is defined here and since the
passport jwt middleware is using the
json web token npm
library we might as well use the same
library to
issue the jwt so what we're doing
is we're taking in the user object that
we
have in the database we're going to take
the id
of that user in the database and we are
going to assign it to a variable here
we are going to say that we want this
jwt to expire
in one day usually you'd probably do
this like
two weeks or something but we're just
going to do one day for now
and then the payload of this jwt
is going to be defined as the sub
property we'll have the id
as we talked about when we were
configuring the passport object
and then the issued at will just be
whatever time stamp is
right now then we will sign the token
and we're going to do that using the dot
sign method of json web token library
we're going to sign it with the private
key we imported this
up here at the top so here's the private
key that we imported
and that private key corresponds to the
public key that we're going to verify
later with
then we're going to pass in the expires
in
value and algorithm that we plan to
eventually verify it with and that we
will sign it with so
once we've signed the token we will
return
a token which has the bearer string
at the beginning and then the sign token
and then the expires in
property so we have this function that's
going to issue a new jwt
signing it with the private key living
on the server
and then we're going to come back to our
users routes
and then in the success message we're
going to attach
a token and then a expires in
property and to do this we just need to
um well actually we're going to want to
do this down here because
when we initially create the user we
don't have the id
that was stored in the database yet so
we need to come down here in the
callback
to get that id so we'll say the id
is equal to user dot id
and then we're going to issue this jwt
so i think i've already included the
utils
library so we've got the utils library
up here
so we're going to say the
jwt is equal to utils
dot issue jwt then we're going to
pass in the user and actually i don't
know why i did this right
here the function itself is going to
grab that id
off of the user object so all we have to
do is pass in the user
and then if you remember it returns us
an
object with a token and expires property
so we're just going to grab the jwt dot
token
and jwt dot expires
and there we go we have a successful
response
and once we have saved this user in the
database after registering
the front end client will get this
message
right here so let's do that really
quickly let's run this
make sure that we don't have any errors
going on
looks like the database connected okay
and i'm going to open up
postman which is just an http
um request application it's got a lot of
other stuff i should probably be giving
it more credit than that
but let's go to register i've already
got the post request
set up and in the body we're just going
to require
um i think it was just a username and
password
so we'll say the username will be zach
[Music]
we'll say zack jwt just that we can
distinguish from the passport local
strategy i was doing in a previous video
then the password will be just one two
three my
default debugging password here
so i think that's all that we need for
this request let me just check that
really quick
okay so this is all we need we should be
able to run this and hopefully it works
um let's see what we got for the
response
looks like we had some issues so let's
go back and see what's going on
um hmm
oh of course we have the wrong
route that we're using i just said
register
it's actually going to be i think users
slash register or even maybe even api
slash users we'll find that out real
quick come back to the code
let's look at our index.js okay so we're
going to
okay so it's the slash users route is
what we're going to need
so come back to postman get rid of this
api
we didn't include that now we should be
able to send it
and we get a successful response so
here's our response
success is true here's the user that we
stored in the database
and we'll verify that in a second and
then
here is the token and the expires in
that we
issued using the utils library that we
wrote all right so this is what the
frontend is going to receive as a
response
and then they're going to take this
token and store it
somewhere in local storage so that it
can attach it to every single request
in the future implementing the login
post route is
a little bit more complicated but i'll
post in the implementation
or paste in not post i'm looking at all
these post requests
and what we're doing it's it's pretty
simple but
there's a lot of code here so we'll
start at the top
the first thing that we're doing is
we're going to take
the username that we received from
the login form whatever the user typed
in
and we're going to look in our database
for that username
if we then will assume that we find the
user
and we populate it in this user property
we'll say first if there's no user so if
this
user in the database doesn't exist maybe
this person is trying to log in and they
haven't even registered
we'll just return a 401 code
with a message that says could not find
the user
pretty simple there this next line
if you watch the passport local strategy
you'll understand this exactly
but if you didn't what this is doing is
using that
valid password function so up here
the validate password function and it's
basically going to check
okay is the username um that you just
gave me and the password you just gave
me
are they valid so it's going to take
that plain text password
that the user just typed into the login
form and validate it with the node.js
crypto library and that function that we
already defined so this is going to
either be true or false based on whether
the user logged in
successfully and mind you this is
different from the jwt
remember we have not issued the jwt
yet we'll just assume that they're
logged out so
if this is valid we know okay this is a
valid user we need to give them a jwt
that they can attach to all of their
future requests
so that they don't they don't have to
log in every single time
so here's our issued jwt it's exactly
how we issued it down here
and then we will attach that with the
same exact
response body that we did earlier we
also probably should just put in the
user
property here like we did in the
register route
and then finally if the user did not
log in successfully they gave us the
wrong password or the wrong username
whatever then we will return
this response where it says you entered
the wrong password
and it's just going to be a 401 response
because that is like the unauthorized
http code all right and then we're going
to catch any errors just put it through
standard express middleware and catch it
in our air handler
i don't even think we have one
implemented for this but
that's kind of what that's going to do
all right so
we've got both of our routes implemented
and let's come back to postman
just make sure that this is going to
work alright
so we'll go to login and
let's just copy the body that we put for
the register because it should be the
same
so here's the user that i already have
registered in our database
um here's the correct password for that
user
let's make sure that we have the right
path here and click send
and we get a success is true and we get
the same exact response
here is our jwt that we will store in
the browser at some point
all right so we are done with the bulk
of our work here
the last thing that we need to do is
just test to see
if our passport jwt middleware
is working correctly so far we haven't
even tested the passport jwt middleware
we've just be been doing the basic
username and password register
and login and issuing the jwt
all right so coming back to vs code the
way that we're going to test this is in
this first route
which is the protected route and
we are going to pass in the passport
middleware
right here so we'll say
passport.authenticate
and then we're going to say that we want
the jwt strategy
and we're going to pass in an object
that says session
false and the reason that we do that
if you're familiar with the passport
local strategy that we did in previous
videos
we were using the passport session
middleware
to actually interact with the express
session middleware
but we're not using this here because
we're using jwts
so we say that that's false all right so
what this is going to do is execute that
verify callback
so this function right here and if we
successfully validate the jwt that has
attached the request
it should let us into this route
so we should be able to print something
let's see if we can get in here all
right so we'll just say
res.status200.json.com
will stay consistent here is true
message
is going to be you are
authorized
we are now ready to test this out so
let's go to pat to postman
and we'll come over to the protected
route
again we need to put in that path
and here's where the magic comes in but
also kind of
gets really confusing we have to attach
the jwt
that this user owns to the authorization
header
now in postman you have the option to
put it here
in the authorization tab
you could just do bearer token and you
put the token here
but we're not going to do that we're
just going to stick with basic http
headers
to keep things simple so we're going to
use the authorization header
and then the value that we will pass in
is that token that we received
over when we registered or logged in
so we just logged in so we're going to
take this entire token
including the bearer portion and we're
going to
copy that into the value right here
so this value because it's in the
authorization header
and because it says bearer with the
space and then the token
which is exactly what the passport jwt
middleware is expecting
that middleware is going to take this
value
it's going to run it through the
verification function using the json web
token library
and hopefully authenticate us correctly
so we're just doing the get request
let's send it and it says success true
you are authorized so in this case we
just
copied in the bearer token here the jwt
in postman but obviously if you're
implant implementing an application
you're going to do this on your front
end client so for example angular
and you're going to want a way to you
you'll probably store it in local
storage
after you've been issued this and then
you will
write some sort of logic to attach it to
every request
but that's not the purpose of this video
this video is just to show you how to
configure
the passport jwt strategy so if you
wanted to watch that that'll be probably
the
one of the next videos or something like
that
but the last thing i wanted to do in
this video
is just kind of a quick recap to show
you exactly how
you're going to be using this alright so
every time
every route that you want to protect
using
jwt authentication you're going to use
this syntax right here if you wanted to
simplify it even further you could
probably write
write yourself a middleware that just
calls this method
and then you only have to pass in like a
couple letters
but if you wanted to you can pass in
this exact syntax
every single time now this
is very different from the passport
local strategy
because if you remember when we did that
if you watched that video
we only called the passport.authenticate
method
one time and we called it in the login
post route and then after that what we
were doing to check whether this user
was
authenticated was saying if
request.session.passport.user
exist or i think we had a shorthand
method
if request dot is authenticated
that's how we were validating whether a
user was logged in
but since jwts are by default stateless
we're not using sessions we have to call
this
every single time so that the passport
middleware can
you know grab the jwt that's included in
the request and verify it
so it's pretty simple actually this all
you're going to be using
attach it to every request that you want
to authenticate
and you could even come over to your
passport verification and have some sort
of different
logics you could say in this part of the
body
you could say if user.admin if you
wanted to validate like an
admin property or something you can get
pretty creative with it
but that is the basics of using the
passport jwt strategy
i just want to take a few moments to say
congratulations
if you've made it to this point the
remainder of the video is completely
optional for you you can fully say that
you understand
the basics of user authentication in
node.js
express and passport.js if this video
has connected the dots for you in one
way or another
i'd really appreciate if you went and
checked out my channel um much smaller
channel
than the one that i'm on right here but
i make a lot of web dev related videos
and post on a weekly basis at least at
this point
so go check it out subscribe like a
video
that would be extremely helpful to me
and i'd really appreciate it
alright the last part of this video as i
said is completely optional and we're
going to be covering
two things number one we're going to be
covering
how do we actually take passport js out
of the equation
with the jwt strategy believe it or not
the passport jwt strategy is just using
the json web token library under the
hood
and we can do the same thing well
passport js has a lot of strategies that
really alleviate a lot of the work that
you would have to do
and i'd highly recommend using them the
jwt strategy is a little bit unique in
the fact that
i don't think that the passport jwt
strategy
adds a whole lot of incremental value to
you now that is of course if you
understand
what you're doing and since we just
talked for many many hours
to learn how all of this works and we
actually do know what we're doing
we can implement our own jwt strategy
pretty easily and then in the final part
of this video we're going to walk
through the basic
implementation of a jwt strategy
with angular on the front end now of
course this will not apply to all people
not everyone is an angular developer or
has an interest in that
but i did want to tack it on to the end
in case you are working within the
angular framework and are confused
how do you take all these concepts and
translate it to
you know the front end and use local
storage to keep your users logged in
and communicate with the backend that we
just wrote all right
let's go ahead and first jump into how
do we write
our own custom jwt authentication
strategy
so what you see on the screen here is
our application it looks a little bit
different
got a slightly different environment as
i'm recording this video which is kind
of recorded a separate time
as an addition to this course so
everything is the same though don't
worry about that
let's go ahead and open up postman just
so that i can prove that out to you
so if we go to the register route we'll
put in
another test user and we'll send that
request
and it's not going to work because we're
not actually running the server
at the moment so let's go ahead and run
the server
try that again and we should get a
successful creation of the user
now let's copy these same credentials
oops
we'll copy the same credentials into the
login right here
click send and we should get a bearer
token
let's copy that bearer token go to our
protected route
and drop that into the authorization
header value click send and it says you
are successfully
successfully authenticated to the route
so as you can see it's the same exact
thing
nothing has changed but what i want to
do now is
close out of here and i want to create
a new branch so we're going to create a
new branch
called custom jwt
and what we're going to do on this
branch is we're going to completely rip
out
the passport js implementation and add
in our custom jwt
implementation you might think that
sounds really difficult but it's
actually not
and although there is a really good use
case for passport
passport as a middleware and framework
such as the local strategy and a lot of
the delegated
authentication such as you know the
social logins
truthfully the passport jwt strategy
does not really do a whole lot of heavy
lifting for us
quite honestly i prefer to do my own
custom implementation when working with
jwt
so the most obvious place to start is
going to be in the passport.js file
where our implementation
sits let's take a look at what we might
have to change
so the first thing that i see in the
options is that we have this
method called extract jwt from auth
header
as bearer token so we need to be able to
take the off authorization http
header and grab the correct token
and parse it in our code as i mentioned
earlier passport
js is doing that for us so we don't have
to do it on our own
but as we're ripping passport out right
here we're gonna have to write a custom
function to do this
furthermore in the main implementation
this is just a middleware so
we're just going to replace that with
our own custom
middleware function that's all it really
is is just a function
and we're basically going to verify the
jwt that is passed through the request
and then you know either authorize or
deny access to
that given route and then that's going
to play out
once we go to the routes over here where
you see
in the protected route we're using this
passport.authenticate method
we're just going to replace that with
our custom
middleware function that we're about to
create so just to start us
off let's go ahead and and start
removing some things so let's comment
out the passport declaration up here
and let's also remove the authenticate
method right here and see how that
changes
everything for us so we should still be
able to
start the application and then go over
to postman
go to the protected route and we can
uncheck this authorization
and click send and it says you are
successfully authenticated now that's
obviously not true
because what we did was just remove the
middleware that's authenticating us
so we need to replace this with some
other middleware
and we're just going to throw this in
the utils file
because we've already got this being
imported so
let's open up utils and you can see we
have a lot of our helper methods in here
and what we can do is actually create
our authentication middleware as well
so let's go ahead and create a new
function
and we'll say this function will be
called off middleware
something like that and what we need to
pass in
as with any middleware is going to be
the request
object the response object and next
and then of course we're going to create
that as a function so we'll drop it down
here
by default let's go ahead and just
send a 401 unauthorized error so the 401
http status code is for unauthorized
and if we were to um let's save this
go back to our users right here and add
back in the passport
authenticate method and then uncomment
or yeah uncomment the passport
import this is going to put us back to
where we were
and if we go to this protected route and
we've got the authorization removed
and click send we should get this
unauthorized
response and if we click through this
let's see we can look at the headers
and it says the status is 401
unauthorized
and then it explains that error similar
to 403 forbidden
but specifically used for when
authentication is possible but has
failed
or not yet been provided so that's a
good
just overview of the 401 error and we
can also see that we're doing this
in the res dot status right here uh in
the login route so we're already
a little bit familiar with this but by
default we're going to make this off
middleware just send that 401 and maybe
we can even
stay consistent with our login so
instead of just
sending it we'll say res.status
and then give it a payload or a response
body
so we'll say res.status is 401 the
success is false
and the message is going to say you are
not
authorized to visit this route
from this point let's go ahead and copy
one of these down
and replace our export so that we have
the off middleware export so that's
going to export it from this file
and now we can actually use it over in
users.js
so we've got this import already so
let's
let's comment out passport again just
that we're not we're not importing that
anymore and we can
we can go ahead and delete that because
we're not going to toggle that back on
yet
or anymore so we'll go to utils.off
middleware
and that's really all you have to pass
in you don't have to pass in any
you know parameters or arguments or
anything
so let's go back to postman
and try out our
protected route so let's click send
and see what the response is we get a
success false
you're not authorized to visit this
route and the reason we're getting that
is because when we run this route
instead of getting
what's in the body of the route we're
passing through this
off middleware that we just created and
it's
by default giving us an unauthorized
status
but that of course is not what we are
wanting to do here we're wanting to
get the jwt that was passed into the
request
and then pull out the token from that
and validate that token using the json
web token library
because after all that's all that
passport jwt is doing in the end
what i have pulled up here is actually
the passport jwt strategy
implementation and you'll see that on
the verify jwt
this is all that's happening you're just
using the json web token library
to verify the token itself so that's not
going to be all that difficult for us to
do
and then furthermore we have the extract
jwt
which is going to be if we come back
here
go to passport and see this method right
here
so the from off header as bearer token
so if we were to go to that same
repository we can go to the
um off header or no the
yeah the offheader.js which is going to
have
a parse offheader method which is going
to basically call the extract
jwt and then this has a bunch of
different ways that we can do this
depending on what our header looks like
but in our case
it's from auth header as bearer token as
we saw
right here and what that's doing is
calling another method
which has some utility functions so on
and so forth
so that's not all that difficult to
implement either let's go ahead and see
what that request header looks like so
if we were to
drop into the off middleware in
console.log
the request and then i believe we can
just
say the request.header if i'm
remembering this correctly
and then we came over to postman and we
went to the headers
turned back the authorization header and
click send
and then we'll see something printed
here so maybe i did not
uh print this correctly so i'm printing
a function not
the actual header so i think i have to
say request.headers maybe instead
so let's go back send this request again
and now we're getting something a little
bit better so we're seeing our header
printed out now let's go back to postman
and instead of this authorization header
let's go ahead
and copy the token itself and
turn this one off and then go to
authorization
and click bearer auth so if we copy in
this token
and click send we should still get the
same
header so we we're always going to get
this authorization property
and that's kind of what it means when
we're looking at the passport
implementation
and it says that we need to extract jwt
from the auth header as bearer token
that is
us telling the passport library hey
we expect this certain format so parse
it accordingly
so that's basically what we're saying is
we always expect
this exact format to be passed in and in
our utility method we're going to have
to take that into account
so the next question is how do we
actually parse through this token
well we can actually split the token
because
as you see in the format down here
there is no spaces other than between
the bearer
and the token itself so if we have a
valid bearer token
we can just split it with a javascript
method
so let's go ahead and make a variable
called token
parts and then what we're going to do is
we're going to say request.headers.split
and we're going to split it by a single
space
now if we console.log the token parts
instead of just the entire header you're
going to see
something that we can work with a little
bit easier so let's go ahead
and remove this we'll go back to no off
because i think it's a little bit more
straightforward when we're just passing
in
the authorization header and let's go
ahead and click send
and it looks like we got some issues
here
it says request.headers.split is not a
function
and that is of course because i'm not
thinking
at all trying to talk and teach and code
all at the same time it's a little bit
difficult sometimes
i don't want to split the headers i want
to split the
headers.authorization property
let's try that that might work a little
bit better
and this time we should get an array so
our array has the bearer and the token
keywords and then from here we basically
need to
check to make sure that this is the
correct format because what if
what if we get something that's
incorrectly formatted
passed as an authorization key that
would obviously be
invalid so what we're going to do here
is we're going to say if the token parts
0 is equal to the word bearer
which is what we would expect and
the token parts number one so
the first index which would be the
actual token
if that matches a certain regular
expression
then it's going to be valid in that
regular expression as we learned with
the jwt
portion of this course is always going
to be a series of characters
with a period and then another series of
characters
with another period somewhere here
if i can track it down and find it
so right here is the second period and
then some more characters to follow
so the way that we can validate that is
with a regular
expression that basically just looks
like characters period
characters period more characters if it
doesn't follow that format then it's
invalid we don't want to
let the user into the route so we can
actually use the string
matching function and we can pass in a
regular expression
that i've already written so this course
is not about regular expressions so
you're just going to have to take my
word on this this right here is going to
basically say
look at the string that we've got down
here
and ask you know whether it fits that
format of characters
dot characters dot characters and if it
is then
it's not going to equal a value of
null so if it does match then
it's going to give you a results array
if it does not match it will return null
so
if we check and make sure that that does
not return null
then we know that we have a valid jwt
format
so we're basically saying if we make it
into the body of this if statement
then our token is valid we are now ready
to actually
write the verification portion of this
with the json web token library
now we've only imported our
private key up here but we also need to
import the public key in order to
validate this
so remember we sign it with the private
key and we
verify it with the public key so that's
the order we're going in
so let's go ahead and copy this down and
we're going to grab instead of the
private key we're going to grab
the public key and then we're going to
change the variable name copy this down
change private key to public key
and update the variable here let's make
sure that we're getting that
correctly first so if we get here and we
have a valid token which we should
we should be able to console.log the
public key
constant variable so we restarted
let's try to visit the protected route
and you can see that we're
getting that public key printed out just
fine so that's working
now we just have to implement the json
web token verify
method that it comes pre-built with so
if you were to go to the json web token
documentation on npm and
search for the jwt dot verify method
you can see that it takes in a token
which is going to be the jwt
a secret or public key so that will be
our public key
and then of course we have some options
and a optional callback function
you can read through this but i'm going
to go back and just implement it
and show you exactly how to use it so
we've got the imported json web token
library
and all we need to do is come down in
here and say
let's say verification variable equals
json web token
dot verify now it's going to ask us for
a token
which we're going to give it the token
parts at index 1 which is the actual
token
we're then going to pass in the public
key
and then in the options it asks us
whether we
want to supply an algorithm so if i were
to go back to this
documentation we have an options
and algorithms which is a list of
strings with the names of the allowed
algorithms for example hs256
blah blah blah so all we have to do is
pass in the algorithms and then in the
array
we need to pass in rs 256
and you might ask how did i decide on
that algorithm
well if you remember from the
passport.js
file where we were given the options to
the passport middleware
we were basically saying i want to
extract it as a bearer token
which we did here in these lines right
here
then what we said is i want it to be
using the public key
so we passed in the actual public key
just as we did
right here and then finally we said that
we wanted the rs256 algorithm which is
basically the public
private key pair or asymmetric
cryptography
so that's what we're doing here in the
algorithms section
so we're basically giving it the same
options we're just doing it more
directly
so let's go ahead and console.log
the verification and see what we're
getting
so let's go back to our postman if i can
get there
and click send so we sent the request
we'll come back here and we're getting
this value right here
which is going to basically
be an invalid value if it was not
successful or will get this
object if it was successful so let's go
ahead and manually
put in the wrong key to see what happens
if it's not
so we'll just remove this first
e at the beginning of the bearer token
and click send and now we're going to go
back to
our library here
and it's going to say json web token air
invalid token
as you can see here this has thrown us
an
air and we don't want that in our
application we want to handle all of our
errors
and if we were to go back to our
documentation here for this
method it's going to give us an
asynchronous
way to do it and a synchronous way to do
it let me just get rid of this
search so we don't see that and for the
synchronous
method it says if a callback is not
supplied function
acts synchronously returns the payload
decoded if the signature is valid
and optional expiration audience or
issue issuer are valid if not
it will throw the air so that's
basically telling us that we need to
handle
an error if we're doing it synchronously
which is how i want to do it here just
to
stay simple so we can use the built-in
try catch block so we'll say try
catch and then pass in the air and
if we go ahead and run
this method right here if i can copy it
correctly
if we run that right there it should
pass and if it
if it does not pass it will throw an
error and at that point we can
console.log the error just to see what
we're dealing with
so let's go ahead and see if we can
verify it
so basically if we don't make it to the
error
state then we know it was successful so
we've reconnected
let's send the request with an invalid
request
and you'll see that we have printed out
the air now so it looks like it through
the air but we're actually just printing
it and handling it gracefully
so based on this all we need to do now
we've just kind of tested everything out
let's get rid of this console log
statement
let's also not print a variable that we
don't have anymore that's a problem
and then we'll come down into the catch
block and if we have an error
that's where we're going to put this
status
of 401 so as of right now
if it was successful it's not going to
do anything it's not going to return
anything
if it's unsuccessful we're going to get
this message right here
so if we go back to postman we should
expect
to get the you are not authorized to
visit this route message
which is what just happened so that's
working great
and now what we need to do let's go
ahead and assign
this to a verification variable once
again
and now what we're going to do is pass
the next callback in here so we'll just
say next
and that's going to pass us through to
the
next route at this point what we could
do is we've got this verification stored
and let's go ahead and console.log it
one more time
just to see what we're dealing with and
at this point i need to add back in that
uh e character that i just
manually removed from this token so now
it should be valid
and when we send the request we're not
going to get any response yet because we
haven't done anything here
but in the terminal if we scroll to the
bottom we should get this little
block of code which is some useful
expiration date of the jwt token which
we can then
use on the front end to you know set
expires headers
or expires in local storage and stuff so
it would be helpful to pass this along
so all i'm going to do is say on the
request object
i'm going to going to assign the jwt
equal to the verification
and then i'm going to say next to pass
it to the next
middleware in the chain so at this point
we're passing it to the next middleware
in the chain
and now we have this jwt property so
we're going to drop into this route and
now we should be able to
console.log the request.jwt
and if we console.log that successfully
then we know that it was a successful
verification
and we should see the same object being
printed despite the fact that we're not
printing it in our middleware anymore
let's go back to postman click send
and it says you're successfully
authenticated which is good
good news and you'll also see this jwt
that we had attached to the request
object so believe it or not
we are done ripping out passport.js and
implementing our own strategy
so if we were to come to the passport.js
file and just click
delete on this whole thing we should
still be able to run our app so let's
start it it's going to crash because
we're currently importing that into
app.js
so if you remember we're configuring
passport right here
and do we do anything else yeah we're
importing passport up at the top
just want to make sure we're not using
it anywhere else
let's save that
and see what else looks like i missed
one so on line 22
here's the initialization call we'll
delete that out
click save and it looks like we're
compiling
correctly now we've deleted passport
entirely i don't think that we have any
other references to
passport let's go ahead and check so
that's just in the package
json and then the readme so we're
looking good we have no more references
to
the passport library in our code and now
we should be able to go through the
entire flow that we went through
previously
with our custom strategy so let's go
ahead and try it
we'll start with the register route
we'll put in a new user
click send we've created the new user
we will update our login route to
log in our new user we'll click send
there
we've just been issued a new bearer
token
and then we'll come to the protected
route copy in the bearer token
and click send and it says you're
successfully authenticated
if we you know delete some stuff here
and
pass in an invalid bearer token and
click send
it's sending the request and not
returning anything for some reason
and i've actually got an error in my
code that i forgot to
account for because it's not returning a
request
so the reason that's happening is
because
remember we're verifying whether this is
a valid token
in the first place and only if it's a
valid token
are we trying the verification so we
need to provide
an else statement to catch any
time where the the actual syntax of the
bearer token
is wrong and we'll return the same
unauthorized status if that's the case
so now if we come back and click send we
should get an
unauthorized response so i'm glad i
caught that
but basically that's just a
demonstration of how we implement our
own
custom jwt strategy and it's what i use
in a lot of my apps for when i'm just
getting started and
you know providing a basic
authentication strategy
once again you can check out the github
repository associated with this course
and go to the custom jwt
branch to see the code that i just
worked on and
last but not least let's go through
how do we implement this jwt strategy
on the front end and sync it up with all
the code that we've written on the back
end in express
today we're going to be talking about
how do we
take the passport jwt strategy that we
implemented in our express application
and
kind of port that into a frontend that
will handle the jwt
and attach it to each of our http
requests
so we're going to do this with angular
and
the reason being is because i
for one know angular better than most of
the front-end frameworks
and number two it is very compatible
with jwts
now if you were to um let's say
make an express app and you used ejs
as a templating language and that's how
you built your front end
now in that case sure you could
you know somehow implement a jwt
[Music]
front end but it's going to be a little
bit more difficult because
the pages that we would be loading on
the front end are going to be
coming straight from the server well as
in an angular application it's an spa or
single page application
which means everything happens in the
browser
so that includes the um the jwt stuff
and so it's just very compatible for
what we're doing here
like i said in previous videos the goal
of this one
is not to teach you how to write an
angular app
so i'm assuming that you already know
kind of the basics of angular we're not
going to do anything
too crazy but i'm not going to be
walking you through the structure
of how angular works and all that good
stuff the goal here is to show you
exactly how we take
our express server that is issuing us
jwts
and translate that into the front end so
to do that i want to first
walk you through what i've already
provided you with
in the previous video i introduced the
github repository
it'll also be in the description here
and
when you download the repository on the
master branch you're going to have
a blank template we implemented the
first part of that template in the
express
application in the last video and then
the second part of the template is what
we're going to be doing in this video
and that is sitting in the angular
directory
and if we open up the main part of this
application you'll see several folders
already built for you and they're all
connected up so
this app kind of runs already even
though we haven't implemented the actual
methods
so i'll walk you through it real quick
let's start an app.module
let's see what we've got here so i've
already set up the routes for us
so if we visit login register and
protected
it's going to load the login register
and protected components
so that's already set up for us in
angular kind of gets that out of the way
we are declaring those components here
let's see here's the router module and
this is important we have to
implement the use hash option because
we have our api from the express
application
and then we have the routes from the
angular application and we don't want
those to conflict
now down here i kind of debated whether
i was going to put this in here
but this is the setup for
our http interceptors and
that is something that we're going to
actually implement but i've left
the the structure of it
intact and it's already included in the
main module so you don't have to worry
about doing that but
this right here is a very special syntax
you're probably not used to seeing it if
you don't work in angular
a lot so that's the app module
which is the base of the application
app component just has three links
so that you can load each of the routes
and then
i actually put the routes below so we're
pretty much staying on one page the
whole time
and just toggling between the routes by
clicking these buttons up here
i can go ahead and run this just so we
can see what that looks like
i don't think we should get any errors
so it loaded successfully
let's visit in the browser
and you can see that our application is
very far from beautiful
the goal here is not to style it up or
anything
we just want the functionality so as i
said
if you click each of these routes
they're going to display below
so right now we're at the home route so
nothing is being displayed
but if we click login you'll see a
little
ugly login form if we click register
you'll get the register form and then
the protected route
is just going to give us a message and
in this case we don't get a message
because we're not authenticated
so that's kind of the the entirety of
this application
obviously it's not something that you
would show to any user but
it does give you the setup and the
the logic behind how you would start an
application okay so let's come back to
the code
walk through a couple more things that
we've got set up
and i'll kind of show you what we're
going to be doing in this video
so the first thing we've got is the off
service
this is a service that we're going to be
spending a good amount of time in
as you can see we've got five different
methods that we need to implement
in order to kind of manage that jwt that
was
issued from the express server next up
we have
an auth interceptor which we have to
implement the intercept method for this
what this is going to do basically is
take
each http request and it's going to
attach the jwt
to it so this is kind of the magic
behind the scenes
then of course we have each of our
components so the login
protected and registered components
let's see what i have implemented here
we we basically just have
the form functionality implemented so we
don't have to walk through that logic
so you see here we have a register form
then
when we submit the register form it's
going to call this method
which sits right here and in this
on register submit we're just going to
take the
username and password we're going to
make a post request to our express
application which is on localhost 3000
and then we're going to get a response
and if it's successful then
we're going to navigate back to the
login so don't
worry too much about what's going on
here this is basically just making the
request
to get the jwt from the express server
and then same with the login you're
going to see something very similar
you have a form here you have a method
on submit
and that method is going to make a post
request to the login route
of the express application so go ahead
i know i didn't cover absolutely
everything
so go ahead on your own time and just
pause the video
and take a look through this angular app
just get familiar enough with it and
then we will get into
actually implementing the jwt
um strategy here i think the first thing
that we should do
is implement this service called off
service
now this is going to manage how we
store and retrieve the jwt token or jwt
that we have been
issued from the express server before we
do that though
let's go and quickly review what we're
getting
from the express server so if you
remember from the last video
when we register a new user let me
go ahead and register a new user real
quick
we send that oh and it's not going to
work because the express app is not
running yet
so we need to first run the express app
okay express app is running we can go
back
and actually let's how do we cancel this
request
um cancel all right so let's send it one
more time
this time we should get success true and
here is our jwt so this is how we're
getting information from the express
server
and then if i wanted to log in with that
same exact user
i could do that with the login route and
it's going to give me the same exact
data
so this is the data that the angular
application expects
and once we get that data we're going to
basically take this token
and put it into local storage so
that is what this auth service
is doing it's basically saying okay once
we get the response we want to set local
storage
then the logout method will basically
delete stuff from local storage
so on and so forth to help us out and
kind of keep things straight
um in our heads i'm going to copy in
this response
that we get from um
the express application when we register
or log in a user so i'm going to put
this here
and just comment it out so that we have
a representation of what we are
expecting to receive
and this when we implement this first
method here
the response object should be this
right here so the first thing that we
need to do
in the set local storage this is going
to be
when we receive our jwt and we need to
put it in local storage
so the first thing that we need to do is
actually
figure out when this jwt
expires so in the response body up here
we're going to get a value of one day
to make things a little bit easier and
not have to deal with javascript dates
and stuff
we're going to use a library called
moment.js which is
here's the documentation for that and
it's pretty simple to be honest
moment is the main function gives you
the current moment
and then you can do whatever you want
with it you can format it
here's like the live on the right side
here is like the live
updates to these pieces of code
you can also do things like add
certain amount of days so this is what
we're going to be doing
we're just going to be doing moment.add
and then pass in
that 1d which represents one day
so come back to
the angular application we're going to
just store
let's say expires equals
moment
[Music]
dot add and then we're going to say the
response
object dot expires
in alright so we've got the
response object right here and then the
expires in property
so basically this right here equals 1d
and if we add that to the current moment
that's going to give us the
time that this jwt expires
after we've figured out when this jwt
expires we need to set two things into
local storage to do that we can just say
local storage dot set
item
and this set item method is going to
take
two values so first is the name
of or first is the key and second is the
value
so we'll say token is the key and then
the value of that if we look up in
the object that we should be getting
here
it's going to be dot token so
we will say response object dot token
and if you remember that token is has
the bearer
included so just keep that in mind as we
go forward
local storage dot set item and
expires so that's going to be our second
one
and that is going to be
the response object as well but we
actually have to do
a few things to this or excuse me this
is not on the response object it is what
we just set right here
so we need to pass in expires and then
we need to do a few things to it
so first we need to get the value
of this so this is just a javascript
method
that's going to take the primitive value
of a string
object and then we will say
json.stringify
and pass in that value so
nothing too special going on here it's
literally just to get us
in the correct format and that's pretty
much it for the set local storage method
so we'll receive this object when we log
in or register
and then angular is going to take that
object
pass it into set local storage we'll see
where this is actually
used a little bit later but it's going
to take
that response object and set these two
items in local storage
now to log out we're just going to
remove those two items
so we can say localstorage.remove item
and we just pass in the name of the item
that we want to remove
so once we remove these items from local
storage
when angular checks to see whether they
exist it won't find them
and it will make the user log in again
so that's kind of what is going on here
the next thing that we're going to do is
this get expiration method and that is
because
this method is going to be required to
see if a user is logged in
now if we issue a jwt
to a user then that means from
um that the express application has
already
done all of the crypto cryptographic
logic
to decide whether the user is actually
valid
so if the angular application receives
this
response then we know that they are
pretty much logged in so all we have to
do is check whether the
jwt is expired and if it is expired we
need to delete it from local storage
otherwise we can consider this user to
be logged in
so to grab that expires from
the local storage we're just going to
paste in a few lines here
so first we're going to get the item
it's not expires at it should be
expires as we set it up here
and then we're going to figure out um
the so json parse is going to take the
json our
object and make it a javascript object
this last return
value is just going to calculate using
the moment library
it's going to just calculate the point
in time
which this jwt actually expires
and then we'll come up in the is logged
in
route or not route but function and
we're going to
take this value the expiration value and
see if the current time
is before or after it to do that
we just say return moment
dot is before this is just a method that
we have available to us
and then we're going to pass in this dot
get expiration
which will return us the moment that
this jwt
expires and if
it returns true then that means that the
jwt is still valid
and we should still be logged in then
the last method here
is just going to return the opposite
of this dot is logged in pretty simple
now that we've implemented this off
service let's go ahead and see it in
action before we do that i want to
remind you what is happening
when we register a user using the
register component
when the user presses submit
on the register form this post request
is going to be sent out to our express
application which is running over here
which will return that big
object that we were talking about and
looked at
and then once we receive that response
object we're going to pass it into the
set local storage method
which will set our token and expires
properties in local storage
let's test this out go to google chrome
right now if i refresh the page you'll
see that in the application
we don't have anything in local storage
for this
application now let's go to
the register route and let's put in
something like jwt test
and then a password of one two three and
when we click register we should be
redirected to the login route
and you'll see that these two the token
and the expires has been
set to the local storage we also
will console log the user object that we
got
back from the express server just to see
that it was successful
at this point we actually don't even
need to log in
necessarily because we've got these
things set in the local storage
but why don't we just go and do it jwt
test
one two three and then we're going to be
redirected to the protected route
but it says you are not authorized to
visit this route
no data is displayed and the reason
being
is because we have not yet implemented
our
interceptor which is going to take the
jwt that is sitting
right here in local storage and append
it to every http request
that we make in our express applica or
our angular application
in other words we need to find a way to
when we click
visit protected route while there is a
token
that is valid in local storage to get it
to actually work
looking at the protected component
you can see that what this is doing when
we
click visit that route so ng
on init so when this component is loaded
the first thing that it will do
is make a get request to
this link right here which on our
express application
as you saw in the last video is only
going to allow users to receive the
correct data
if they are authenticated with a jwt
that the express server deems as valid
right here is the protected route and if
we
are not authenticating correctly if our
if we don't have a jwt attached to this
get request or the jwt is invalid
we should receive a 401 unauthorized
error
if we are valid then we should receive
this message right here
so here's the message you are authorized
okay so let's close this out go back to
the protected component
and you'll see that if we get a response
we're going to print
the message attached that response so we
should see
what we were just looking at in the
express application
if it was successful but if we have an
error which is going to be a status of
401
or unauthorized the message is going to
be you are not authorized to visit this
route
and we saw that earlier in the browser
so let's go solve the last piece of the
puzzle open up the auth
interceptor which right now is empty
i'm going to paste in the implementation
here
and then we're going to walk through it
so let me indent this correctly
okay so again this is not an angular
tutorial you're going to have to read up
on
interceptors which you can find on their
documentation it gives you a lot of
examples
but basically what this is doing is kind
of intercepting
every http request that angular
is sending out and it's going to attach
or it's going to run the intercept
method so
what we're doing here is first we're
grabbing
this should not be id token should be
just token
we're grabbing the token from local
storage
and then if there is an id token so if
we get a token from local storage
then so far we're good what we're going
to do
is clone the request so we're taking the
current request
that is going through the chain of
interceptors
it's kind of like middleware and express
almost
and we're going to take that and clone
it but this time
we're going to set the authorization
header
equal to the id token so that should set
authorate authorization header equal to
bearer and then a space
and then the jwt then we say
return next dot handle and pass in that
cloned object
so that should basically right here that
should
successfully attach the jwt
if we don't find a token which is very
possible if the user is not logged in
then we just return next.handle the
request
and there's going to be no authorization
header whatsoever
we now have an auth interceptor which
should attach
this jwt token to our request
now if we go to the browser to our
application
technically if we visit this protected
route right now
it should say that we are authorized
because
you remember we already logged in and
you'll see that we have the token and
the expires
already in the browser so as long as we
attach
this to our next request it should
authenticate us so let's try that
if you remember from the last request
there was no
author authorization header but now if
we visit the protected route
it says you are authorized and if we go
to the network tab
this is a little bit tricky you're
probably tempted to click on localhost
but we need to click on protected
and you'll see that down in the request
headers
there is this authorization header which
has the jwt that we had stored in local
storage
so that is the basic flow and you can
use this concept
to basically manage your users within an
angular application and obviously there
could be
users with different types of
permissions and
that would require you to come back to
your interceptor and write in some
custom logic to say
okay hey based on what role this user
has
are we going to attach you know the jwt
or not and also you might
be you might have routes on the express
application
that may or may not require
authentication
but hopefully this implementation
so the combination of this auth
interceptor
and the off service hopefully those two
things
along with the previous video where we
talked about
how do we actually issue that jwt have
brought your understanding of user
authentication
um you know to a conclusion and
hopefully this all makes sense
this is just one way that we can
implement user authentication
in our front end or angular app
you're going to see a lot of different
implementations across
a lot of different coding languages the
most important thing
is to understand how everything works
how does the jwt work
and how are we supposed to kind of pass
it from the front end to the back end
once you understand that it should be a
breeze to implement
your own authentication strategy you
never thought that we'd make it to this
point
but we're here we're at the end of this
super long
user authentication crash course and i
want to say a big thank you
if you watched all the way through
that's really an accomplishment to get
through
you know however many hours this took us
to understand all these concepts
and if you are one of those crazy people
that went from the very beginning of
this
uh course all the way to the end here
and didn't skip
anything i'd love to hear from you i'm
on twitter at zg
underscore dev and i'd really love to
hear from you so
reach out tell me what you thought about
this course or just say hi once again
i'd really appreciate if you checked out
my much smaller youtube channel and just
gave it a look
and until next time i will see you later